i've not
listened to this let's listen to it
together
and and see what it what it's about
david jimmy for philly i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired
and listen to your [ __ ] about
unhinged trump supporters and this and
that
make yourself full of [ __ ] i i
got my hat's off to you you can't you
you you can't withstand it david
you got my information [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccino
[Music]
[ __ ] your cappuccinos
[Music]
in the name of jesus from south america
they're coming here
they're coming here they're coming here
they're coming here
from africa
i hear the sound of victory
i hear the sound of victory i hear the
sound of victory
i hear the sound of winning winning
[Music]
winning
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm working my ass off here i'm soaking
wet already
suppression balls you can't hold them
i'm soaking wet already
suppression balls yesterday we had three
big ones really big
suppression balls you don't give me the
umbrella i'm soaking wet already
they put numbers you know they're called
suppression suppression balls
they make you like feel badly so you say
to your wife you said your husband
darling let's go out to dinner and then
we'll come back we love our president
but you know the polls say he can't win
well right now we're leading
in almost everywhere the real
all right welcome everybody i was gonna
play like 10 songs for you guys but
it's just too crazy of a day to do it so
we're going to get right into it
i have memes i have voicemails i have
new
songs i have pathetic new membership
inducements i have my mustard
sweater special day mustard
uh i have a new beard style i have a new
haircut
it's just all happening today and the
reason it's all happening
is that um things are actually things
are actually pretty bad
um we are uh it's a new year
and everything has collapsed
we've got only 929 twitch subs as you
can see
above my head the lowest we've been in a
long time
um youtube cpms have dropped 40 percent
as of january 1st facebook cpms are down
70 percent um
it's really bad so we have to i have no
choice but to pull out
all of the stops today and we may even
take phone calls we may even take phone
calls
thanks to a small fuzzy moss
who says they are also wearing a mustard
colored sweater
yes let's do it okay this may be donald
trump's last rally as president ever
he has not yet arrived in georgia this
is an advance of tomorrow's
senate elections i will be back with you
god willing
in 24 hours with results from
georgia senate elections and then when
this may be the week we may not have
streamed as much as we're streaming this
week
for months you understand what i'm
saying my friends yes
and i see the font peg and all these
people loving it
chai girl uh we have tonight's stream
this may be a long one
we've got probably 15 to 45 minutes till
trump speaks
he may go for hours like fidel castro
we then may open the phone lines if we
get to 100 new members
tomorrow night election results georgia
wednesday 1pm east 10 a.m west
the certification the counting of the
electoral college
with expected interjections and
objections
from republicans hours of possible
debate
culminating in joe biden being on track
to be sworn in of course
uh and mike pence planning to leave the
country on a trip to poland
um just hours after uh the counting of
the ballots on
wednesday so it's going to be an insane
and
absolutely insane week and i'm so glad
to be with you guys
as we speak two seconds ago repeater
left me another voicemail
i might be willing to play some of those
voicemails for you depending on what
goes on
um so we're going to be talking about
all of it okay but just to start
somewhere this is just moments ago on
fox news this is one of the grifter
clowns
uh senator josh hawley who will be
contesting the results on tuesday
watch him be tfo'ed by bret bayer here
and watch for when he does that you know
that face tucker carlson makes that
confused face
i can't do it just he's going to do it
when he gets btfo'd by brett bayer here
take a look this was a smackdown
so the supreme court didn't take up that
that case either they did not take
up the quick case the supreme court
we've seen courts across the country
deal not only with not the standing of
different cases but
also the evidence and some of them
trump's trump judges i just want to
pin you down on on what you're trying to
do good luck
are you trying to say that as of january
20th
that president trump will be president
well that depends on what happens on
wednesday i mean this is why we have the
debate
no it doesn't i mean the states by the
constitution
say they certify the election they did
certify it
by the constitution congress doesn't
have the right to overturn the
certification
oh at least as most experts read it
well congress is is directed under the
12th amendment to count the electoral
votes there's a statute that dates back
to the 19
to the 1800s rather 19th century that
says that there is a right to object
there's a right to be heard there's also
a certification
right that's from 1876 senator and it's
it's the
the tilden hayes race in which there
were three states
and there he goes into the tucker
carlson face as he as he's
uh oh what was that movie uh that
it's like mighty ducks they know the
play or whatever what was that movie as
a
uh josh hawley realizing oh [ __ ] he
knows what the [ __ ] i'm talking about i
was hoping nobody would know what on
earth i'm referring to here
did not certify their their electors so
congress was
left to come up with this system this
commission anyway so we'll have the full
video of that tomorrow
on the show but josh hawley even on fox
news not allowed to get away with his
nonsense so there is that
it was a football movie not mighty ducks
not mighty ducks no i'm sorry you guys
are right yeah i don't remember what
movie it was
uh but it was a movie i watched as a kid
all right let's get
into oh i don't even know what to do
next do i do the repeater arc
do i thank people do a few super chats
dalton haskins says via super chat love
the energy tonight
emma says strong sweater game uh
i noted your sweater there as my
favorite yeah i'm looking at maybe
uh sprucing up my my cloth basically
what i do
once a uh okay i'll thank people and
then do repeater fair
what i typically do my my uh clothing uh
my winter clothing process is sometime
around november
i'll order six sweaters and
six button-down shirts and that that's
my clothing for the win for that's it
that's and then i'll find an equivalent
number of things to donate
uh because i'm not using them or it
doesn't fit well and usually the button
downs are on the show but i'm actually
looking at it at
very strongly actually we're bringing in
legal experts to advise whether they
think it would be disadvantageous or
prejudicial in some way but we're
looking at maybe including more sweaters
on the show uh okay
what am i talking about anyway yeah i
have no idea all right let me do thank
yous just to get us
up to speed and then we'll get to
repeater first of all
from the standpoint of twitch we've had
36 people grab subs
okay so uh 36
and there it is all right now on the
website
let me thank oh boy this is going to be
crazy martin
phillian rodney spurberg
oliver cornelius victor hart
melissa salmonen thanks melissa
christopher bowling
roger rivera justin vaughn
andrew duren is nine adam dunane
is ten alan bakovitz
is 11 mod raymond brousseau
it's 12 it should count as 13 because
the name's so long but we're called
we'll call it 12.
and then anthony ponce is number 13
putting us at 49 guys i have a feeling
we may get those phone lines open today
we have i have a feeling we may do it
okay let me do the repeater arc
just to get this out of the way i have i
have basically three things to play for
you
oh uh guys can we um
moderators we have to ban an asc2
phallus on twitch so moderators please
get that
uh banned right away thank you very much
there it is very very powerful van the
ban hammer will be dropping
i consider the ban hammer as rewarding
as getting a membership
so uh banhammer has been dropped on a
punctuation phallus yeah it's too early
for those you're more likely to get get
away with that during the phone call
segment
so here's the deal with repeater
repeater is a guy who just calls me
over and over and over and over again
saying the same thing over and over
again okay
repeater has left multiple voicemails
while i've been streaming okay we also
have a
fake repeater who called in pretending
to be repeater which is really funny
and i have a repeater song so let's let
me go in the right order
let's start with the song the repeater
[Music]
i have no name for this caller we could
workshop a name together
okay here we go so this started almost
at the stroke of midnight last night
all right let's take a listen to the
first one this is a new caller we've
never had this one before
new caller alert is this david pac-man
i just want to inform you that pac-man
right i just want to inform you that you
are a
idiot idiot once again i'm going to say
it again
now okay so anyway so here's the deal
i'm just going to start playing some of
these
he's been calling all day this last
message is only
11 years sorry 11 minutes old all right
let's take a listen
oh whoops hold on that's muted let me
unmute here we go
uh and here we are donald trump has done
a great job
with kovit it's been amazing it's been
a major success why
because out of all of the cases out
there
99 percent of the people survived it
right okay
repeater 12 minutes ago
so david there have been quite a few
miles
of a brand new steel wall still it's
made out of steel so you can see through
but it is a wall it's made out of steel
just like you have concrete walls just
like you have
wood walls in your house okay and then
six minutes prior to that
david uh i'm gonna say something about
the wall
a wall is not defined by concrete
okay so when you say a wall trump was
originally gonna have a wall built with
concrete
all right and then uh nine minutes prior
david you're a psycho go see a
psychiatrist and get some help
like i said in your last little youtube
video that you made
you said so many things that's not true
you said that there's no
wall built there there are many many
miles
all right four minutes before that
well david here are some more some more
layers of life
okay so anyway you guys get it people
keep calling the phone line so i'm gonna
have to get off of it
but just to give you guys an idea uh i
received how many voicemails
[Music]
yeah you're not gonna get on with me uh
i see what people are calling the
voicemail line right now trying to get
on
um okay this person repeater left
oh my god i i just can't even i can't
even do it
it's just so many okay anyway he left
hundreds and hundreds of uh voicemails
so that's re and then just to close out
the repeater arc
here is fake this is a caller now
satirizing
repeater take a listen to uh this
hi david i said it once
and i'll say it again so why don't you
take off them high heels
kick them off the corner of your studio
there
wipe off that lipstick and listen
99 this is
repeater satirized of people who
get this virus survive
that means that at least one percent
die it could be anywhere from two
percent to three
i've even heard reports on my
backwoods news network that can get up
to six percent
but 99
of people survive so why don't you get
off them
dominion phone calling systems there
and actually listen to what i have to
say 99
of people survive only about six to
seven percent die
right i love i love how it doesn't add
up to a hundred that is that is really
good
um uh yeah that's fo that's a
fake repeater that is just beautiful
okay so we got that out of the way i
just have so much to go over with you
guys because we've been away for so long
um okay and then so let's get
to hold on what i want to keep
everything straight
this is sort of belated but i have a
producer pat and friends rendition this
is a
song now or a song as some would say
um it's a christmas card it's a it's a
digital
it's a musical christmas card for you
guys from producer pat
is that something you would be
interested in pat sings in this
christmas card oh nobody wants all right
well we can skip it
no it's listen don't let me push it on
you if you don't want it
no i'm kidding okay people do want to
hear that let's do it okay
this is pat and friends and i forget
whether
i now pat i asked pat earlier and i
didn't write it down i don't remember if
this is cliff
or or alex or
or oh i don't know who this is this is
pat and friends okay
let's just listen to it this is a
belated christmas card
for you guys from producer pat and
friends
it's christmas time
there's no need to be afraid there
[Music]
people shock that pat's singing voice is
higher yeah i know people very very
uh perplexed by that okay let's keep
[Music]
the going and christmas time
but say you pray is this the same guy
from before is this the third guy
[Music]
it's hard but when you're having fun
there's a world outside your window
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
all right so anyway that's the producer
pat christmas greeting
and it's uh very very exciting of course
as you can imagine
and i'm not familiar being jewish myself
i don't know anything about that song
i've never heard that before but i'm
told that that's not an original that
that's
that's a known song that pat interpreted
i i'm guessing
that's not an original right i'm i'm
accurate in saying that very good
uh all right i'm kidding i know it's not
an original song come on guys
very good so we've uh we've got it
excellent so now we're standing by for
donald trump here we've passed
the musical portion of the show i still
want to hear
from folks via super chat so let's let's
look at some super chats
you know john lennon would have hated
trump
david says that is great satire jacob
asks do i think the new trump call
deserves impeachment
of course of course
with without without question it's worse
than watergate
um i wonder if trump will have to hold
daily rallies to make up for his twitter
account being suspended yeah
what is going to be his outlet thank you
for helping me maintain sanity the last
four years so mentally exhausted from
all this craziness watching you helps
though i appreciate that
jacob asking could you repeat that going
back to re peter certainly
and greta loves the sweater greta loves
the sweater appreciate that thank you so
much
oh jay is saying that the war on
christmas was that song oh no that is a
that's a brutal attack
the war whoa camera's going haywire the
war on christmas was uh pat
doing a christmas song that's really
harsh that's that's mean i thought it
was good
i don't know i thought it was very good
big thank you
to the 16 additional folks who have
grabbed
twitch subs which puts us at
65. we will confirm
open phone lines if and when we get to
100 website
members and twitch subs let me do some
other thank yous because people are just
massively dumping memberships at
joinpakman.com i have a new coupon code
to tell you about in a moment
let me just say some thanks i don't want
to make anybody upset
sean prevost has signed up lydia degasto
paul gangle kieran lee
that's four david ytmnd
all right that's number five lisa craig
is number six
tim white is number seven jacob vio
is number eight ian huntington number
nine
and karma savage karma savage is number
10
which puts us at 75
beautiful number beautiful number okay
i have a few other things here i don't
know what is happening
there's a real problem with these
cameras let's see what's happening on
this other feed
all right we'll get back to that let me
get you um let's just look at a few
other things that i've had
waiting here so we do have a completely
raging pandemic and it's a completely
toxic and depressing situation
as i said before i am expecting that we
are going to hit the case
peak somewhere between gen 10
and jan 15. okay meaning we're one to
two weeks away
from hitting the case peak i believe
that as as we keep vaccinating
and as it starts to get warmer in parts
of the country
i believe we are a couple of weeks maybe
from the case peak
um and i also believe we are about four
to five weeks
probably from the death peak okay
tragic now on the vaccination side
tomorrow on the broadcast show and the
podcast
i'm going to do a deep dive on
vaccination
promises made and promises failed okay
and right now the entire united states
has dosed only 4.6 million people
and that is with a first dose only
remember you need two i think
this in these days we're going to start
seeing some people getting
second doses okay so
vaccination is not going well it's been
a major major failure
and we'll have a deep dive remember at
one point donald trump promised 100
uh 100 million doses by the end of 2020
that quickly fell by the wayside trump
promised 20 million
vaccinated by the end of 2020
and i think we were about 2.8 ish
million with a first dose only
by the end of 2020 so an abject failure
by any measurement and then on the other
side everything trump has taken credit
for from the standpoint of vaccines has
nothing to do with him trump says
thanks to him we developed vaccines much
faster than normal no
mrna vaccines which are basically
instructions to the cell to create
certain proteins okay um it's just a
platform that's been under development
for decades
and it takes less time they did it
faster in europe
they did it faster you know turkish
immigrants did it faster in germany
american companies did it faster it has
nothing to do with trump whatsoever
um so uh that's that
i don't know i don't think there's much
more to say right now but we will
certainly
um say more tomorrow on the broadcast
program
a couple of other things to play for you
i don't know if you guys saw this
but um james doray
who is a youtube host
he finally attacked me yesterday and i
was wondering how long it would be until
he attacked me and it did happen
yesterday
um he said another clarifying moment
for another fake progressive this this
time it's david pakman and my only
comment on this
is that i went in and as you can see
here i immediately
liked his attack tweet on me
and that's all the commentary i have i
just don't think it's worth getting
involved in it anymore
um there's a very trumpian aspect to
sort of like much like trump seizing on
the insecurities and frustrations that
people have but then
you know kind of like just offering
disastrous solutions or non-solutions i
don't want to get pulled into it so
james doray attacked me and i liked his
attack
as you can see there it is circled in in
green
and that's base that's it you know
that's that's
it as far as i'm concerned um
here is video from earlier today hold on
let's make sure we're not missing
anything here in joja no we're not okay
this is video from earlier today
of um a gentleman with a stop the steel
hat being interviewed on fox news
and this gentleman back here starts
flashing the white power
symbol now i want to be really clear i
understand
that the okay sign as a white power
symbol started as a tr it was
not it was just a troll in 2017
there was a joke about the okay symbol
sort of creates a w and a p for white
power it was it started as a complete
joke
but by 2019 it started being used
non-satirically by some and in any case
fox news here ends up it takes kind of a
while
but they cut away from the white power
symbol and just put up a shot of the
white house and it's very obvious that
they don't even know
what the hell to do and the elections
tomorrow do you care about that are you
worried about that
absolutely i think everybody in the
nation should care about it there it is
federal issue in a way who becomes
senators it's gonna have a very big
impact and it's too bad because the
the white power guy is taking attention
away from the idiotic things this guy is
saying
the senate i support senators perdue and
loffler i hope that they are elected
um and you know there it is again
california can come out here
and camp out in zero degree well back
again sleeping bag on the asphalt
maybe a few more voters from georgia
will find the time to get to the polls
and quickly blake do you they just cut
away since you're worried about the stop
to steal and you can tell that this is
this is not like a planned cutaway
because usually if they want to kind of
say like oh yeah we're
we're following trump's about to leave
the white house the lower third would
change and they wouldn't stay on this
shot for so long but they just stayed
the election
uh shenanigans are you worried about the
integrity of the election tomorrow for
lefleur and perdue
yeah absolutely i'm worried about it i
just hope that the correct actions have
been taken to make sure that this time
around
the ballot custody is safeguarded and
there aren't you know extra
okay so there's that um on fox news and
then
also on fox news this is very funny the
people who say facts don't care about
your feelings
now they're all about people are really
upset
staunch conservatives are really upset
well i think people who are staunch
conservatives in our country just feel
so
just so defeated because of this
election they do feel like it was rigged
and then to see what's happening in
georgia
that the democrats could have the house
democrats could have the senate but
she's
in the presidency it's disheartening
guys
it's this guy they just feel like it's
bad
and then um what is this one
oh this is just indistinguishable from
satire
this is um griff jenkins
invites a fan of this woman ainsley
earhart nobody's wearing masks this is
earlier at the rally we're about to
watch
and the guy said has a shirt that says
the only thing worse than kovid 19 is
biden 20.
let's take a look i was going to say go
give terry from detroit our fan
a big hug but we can't do that right
you cannot hug
two seconds on my microphone what do you
want to say to ainsley
we love you ainsley oh terry i love
terry you
terry i want to talk to you you came
from detroit god bless america god bless
the
said she loves you president and she
can't believe you came from detroit
why'd you come from detroit
because i love the president we want to
back him 100 all right thank you jerry
look at that t-shirt what does this tell
you where you got it uh oh
terry what's your t-shirt say the only
thing worse than covet 19 would be biden
20.
what's up and that's the truth okay
thank you so much
god bless you terry thank you thank you
would you believe that guy is a nuclear
physicist isn't that insane it's
hard to believe i know but that guy uh
he he is a literal rocket scientist
actually
okay very good so let's let's uh let's
let's get away from that because it's
just really really toxic
um let's see here it looks as though
trump has still not arrived this is this
is not right now
it's night time in georgia um
they still haven't unblanketed the
lectern so i don't know how far trump is
but
we'll we'll be here chatting about stuff
um for for as long as we need to
big thank you to the additional 26
people who signed up via twitch
which puts us strongly at 101
wow let's just we're doing phone lines
okay we're doing phone lines but let's
just go for 306 the number of electoral
votes joe biden
uh won and let me now uh thank people
who signed up at
real quick nick boskin signed up
and theodore trigg signed up dennis
denise sorry denise ennis has signed up
nancy hall is a new member lindsay
baxtrom has signed up
mark armstrong and david turner
which puts us at 108. i really
appreciate that
thanks everybody and we are standing by
for what may be donald trump's last
rally as president ever
last rally as president i anticipate it
will be mostly about him
this is supposed to be in support of
kelly leffler
and david perdue two senate candidates
who are uh
on the on the ballot tomorrow and
hopefully we'll both lose um
but i believe that it will probably be
mostly about donald trump all right
let's run through some super chats my
friends
david keep up the good work brother
thankful for it thank you
uh max says i know a rocket scientist
who's a trump guy hard to believe but i
guess
there were nazis in nasa so fair point
very very fair point
juan wants to know riwoka i don't um i i
take no position on argentinian league
soccer i just
i root for the argentinian men's
national team in the world cup in copa
america etc
but i don't get involved in the local
league
i hope a guy this depraved of any moral
qualities doesn't become president again
let's hope his last
rally is as crazy as we think it's going
to be i think it's going to be
cuckoo for coco puffs glad you're with
me for it
proud boy leader has been arrested and
rudy is on netflix show
new york versus the mafia maybe i'll
check that out
david for maximum cringe watch don jr
rapping along to vanilla ice on new
year's eve i can't take the cringe i
can't take it
when will we finally hear some pacman
drum solos oh
i don't know we'd probably have to get
to like 500
members or something like that please
play a few seconds of something from
andre
and tunis on youtube i don't know what
that is so i'm not going to do that
right now
thanks for all you do from new zealand
pat not only sings dude can sang
i want to hear more pat that was
gorgeous can i buy that on my amazon
music account wow
ahri says love from australia hoping for
a great relationship between biden and
our
government and then rafael says thank
you for your work david happy new year
from
switzerland and we hope to hear the show
for a long time i hope so as well
very very much hope so um
david what do you think about the proud
boy getting arrested today i don't know
anything about it yet i just heard about
it
i hope that's honey mustard shirt and
not plain no this is uh
i consider this uh deli mustard
is the way i would refer to this it's
not yellow mustard i call it yellow
deli mustard have i seen reports of
trump fleeing to scotland on
inauguration day
yes i did see that there is a theory
that trump is is preparing to go to uh
scotland actually the day before
inauguration july uh
january 19th which would be insane
michael says i think they should do a
second impeachment absolutely
trump deserves to be impeached for that
phone call
the georgia phone call too that phone
call is not specific enough
there's multiple phone calls i'm talking
today about
the georgia phone call gardner says how
much do you think trump will say radical
during this speech i think he will say
it a lot
kyle says trump's loading up on uppers
so he can spout insanity and distraction
tactics
any chance trump trump tells republicans
to stay home to spike republicans not
backing his coup attempt
i hope so but i doubt it i would love
that
aaron says love the show can't wait for
the trash of trump to be over
david and his clueless fools trump stays
in biden goes to gitmo
that can't be real right like did
somebody did somebody really spend five
bucks to tell me
that joe biden's not going to be
inaugurated
16 days from now could anybody really
believe that at this point
i guess thanks for the five bucks i
don't know
bay photo says what will we see from
trump between january 7 and january 19.
it's anyone's guess anyone's guess
how many times will trump say 11 780
votes that's a good question
where did trump learn the fascist
playbook i think it comes naturally to
him i don't know that he i don't know
that it was taught
trump will spend five minutes stumping
for the soon-to-be ex-senators before
spending the next 20 years whining about
being set up and cheated from jail
that's wishful thinking having a diploma
frame
and hanging on your wall does not mean
you are intelligent
true very true are you familiar with the
jewish argentinian tennis player
diego schwarzman he's ranked number nine
i am
very exciting very very exciting
darwin fish says david i've been trying
to recommend a cookbook to you i'm
getting close to sending it to you
because of how much you'll love it
eating out loud by eden grinschpann
must have okay please send nothing we um
we don't even have a mail anymore we
don't have mail anymore so please don't
send anything
but i will look into buying it proud boy
leader enrique tario was arrested for
vandalizing blm sign in dc during last
pb rally
important to wear camo in the jungles of
dc dear god
do you think he'll show yeah trump's on
rude his plane left a while ago should
be landing any moment
carlene says is there enough time to
impeach trump with only 15 days left to
inauguration
no but you can you can impeach him after
the fact
it's a pot you can do that and i believe
it should happen
andrew says check out the great video by
gabriel sterling addressing the fraud
allegations oh yeah i tweeted a little
bit of that
uh i tweeted a um an image
this was part of the present this is so
funny uh
claim 20 2000 felons voted illegally
fact 74 potential felons currently under
investigation
80 66 000 underage teenagers voted zero
underage teenagers voted four people
requested a ballot before turning 18
they were all 18 prior to voting in
november
2400 voted that were not registered to
vote zero unregistered voters voted
a thousand illegally voted using a p.o
box many po boxes are actually
apartments
it's it's fantastic um 4 900 voted past
the legal registration date
zero voted who registered after the
deadline this is all a reference to the
things trump claimed on that call with
the georgia officials
none of which were true um
ten thousand people who died before the
election voted too potentially
discovered but still under investigation
it's it's nuts
really really nutty stuff uh but that
was that was a very interesting
event for sure all right let's do some
twitch messages
began says i was nervous before the
election here in georgia
and now everything is riding on it very
much so
liquid ice says that is a tough question
this is a tough question david at what
point is
fake news considered a threat to
national security
i'm not sure if i see a path to national
stability without doing
something to disarm fake news but it is
a slippery slope
it is and it's a complicated issue um
and once things settle
and joe biden is sworn in we will be
um we will be doing a sort of uh
uh deep dive i guess i would say
on how social media should be regulated
and we already have some clips about it
on
uh on our youtube channel and speaking
of which
i do want to say thanks to the 24
additional twitch subs that just pulled
into the station
putting us at 132 for the day
and let me thank a few joinpakman.com
members darren goodman just grabbed a
membership
monique bowden has signed up jace
winchester doug barnes thanks doug
jackson goldsmith and lucille
crooks uh putting us at 138
wow so we will open the phone lines
because our initial goal was 100 but now
we're going for 306.
uh the number of electoral votes that
that joe biden achieved
a few other super chats that i wanted to
mention
oh oh oh uh i'm sorry i saw this earlier
and i didn't address it people asking is
there a new youtube
sub goal yeah i mean i guess it's one
and a quarter million right
we're at one point we're at 1.21 million
right now on youtube
and i guess 1.25 seems like the natural
next step so uh yeah which is fantastic
would be a great great uh great great
number and as trump is getting ready to
arrive
make sure if you are watching on youtube
hit that subscribe button it's free and
if you're watching on twitch make sure
to hit the
follow button i have to tell you i'm
pretty excited about 100k
on twitch um because we
you know twitch is kind of a new ish
thing and
we're pulling really strongly for 100k
on twitch
and uh someday someday
yeah people saying that this rally is
going to be nuts i think you're right
i think you're absolutely right okay
other super chats coming in trump
drinking
game every time he says rigged stolen or
fake you drink yeah
i i don't recommend that that's going to
lead to alcohol poisoning
trump's posture defies the laws of
physics yeah
uh i don't know if you guys have ever
seen this
uh trump posture
yeah this is really weird stuff
hold on a second there it is
isn't that bizarre i think part of what
it is uh
is probably lifts inside the shoe they
do make once we had an advertiser
who sold shoes with an internal lift so
you can't tell it's a lift
um and it does create a weird kind of
like hinging at the hip it's very
strange very strange
trump also probably needs orthotics you
can see how his feet appear to be
kind of out that's not good that's not
good
he he probably needs something there um
anyway what what what are we even
talking about
we're standing by for a trump rally
scheduled to start very very soon
super chats continue to fly in my wife
said that you make politics enjoyable
thank you prior guy and thanks to mrs
pryor guy i appreciate that
um
what did you did don just get so coked
up he went on an
hour early oh i don't know anything
about that
um david what do you think the chances
are biden will pull a nixon and resign
early and get pardoned by mike pence i
assume you mean trump and not biden
i don't know uh okay
hoping for trump mcsally enthusiasm
let's go david hurry up kelly i have a
lot of lies and narcissism to publicly
parade around yeah this is gonna be a
crazy rally
other super chats david what do you
think about biden offering two grand if
democrats win tomorrow
uh i didn't see did he what did he say
that if democrats win tomorrow that he
would have the ability to do two grand i
haven't seen that yet i've been
preparing for this event
so i missed i'll have to look at it i
miss the logo on black already it will
take time to get used to the new blue
intro on youtube yeah weird we are doing
so part of um we are basically launching
the david pakman show 2.0 i i just made
that up
we used to have different logos and
graphics on all of our different
platforms
we have pulled it all together with the
same look
and now we have um
a new logo and let me see if i can find
an example here just to show you guys
uh on where is this
yeah check this out this is the new
david pakman show youtube
intro and we're putting it all together
all right check this out
i think it's nice i think it's beautiful
it's simple
it's more typographic than uh
sort of sort of like uh graphical in
nature
i i absolutely love it i absolutely love
it and so far the uh
response has been pretty good okay would
another impeachment lead to a rejection
or elimination of a possible 2024 run
for trump
no i mean if he was convicted maybe if
he was convicted maybe
um what's your estimate of the time he
actually brings up the senators he's
there to campaign for
he'll mention them right away i think uh
but i don't think that i think that
today's speech will mostly be about
trump not about the senators
that's just how trump is new haircut
looks sharp yes new haircut and new
new beard style just trying a little
trying a little something new
just boredom that's really it but uh
yeah
it's all it's all happening spent
christmas in rural north georgia i was
happy to see ninety percent of people in
walmart wearing masks and a few asaf
warnock signs that is good news
oh i think this guy really is a trumpet
megaton info bomb dropping on wednesday
you fools are clueless
all right i'll be covering it live let's
see is this rally going to be a bit
predictable
yes trump will mostly talk about himself
that's the prediction
that's that's the only thing i can think
of uh okay
let's see i'm getting a few other
oh hold on a second it looks like
repeater
has continued calling in let me pull
this up
since we've been
oh no i guess he hasn't hold on a second
oh my god now my phone is playing
something weird
so i was trying to find it there uh
let's see did i have any other
voicemails oh i guess i have a troy york
voicemail
if people are interested
yeah i mean i guess i'll play one it's
they've gotten really
boring and predictable but just because
all right here here's just have a troy
york voicemail real quick
uh yes uh david pakman uh
as far as joe biden his little speech
um as professor charles libson i would
say at the university of chicago that uh
joe biden can give those 50 million
uh i'm not even gonna buy it
when i go to the voicemails people start
calling the voicemail number
and uh even though i have it set to go
straight to voicemail it still rings if
i'm
in there i can tell people are bored
with with troy so we don't even need to
deal with it
it's fine actually it's not a big deal
okay
um bigfoot tornado has twitch subbed and
says thank you for the slices of sanity
among the madness i appreciate that
thank you
um and in fact we just
saw an additional 13 twitch subs drop in
which puts us at 151
and then let me also add to that the
people who signed up on my website
kyle mcgregor kara martin
joe trask angela robinson
christa t douglas collins
and charlie moon which is seven putting
us
at 158. yeah okay i'll briefly mention
the the coupon code uh we are uh
launching a brand new coupon code for
2021
the code is better 21. the
idea behind it is pretty
self-explanatory 2020 was a disaster
globally
we are hoping for a better 21. now
because
as you know some of these discounts i
offer are borderline illegal
i am no longer printing the percentage
discount
see how it says coupon code better 21
for a massive discount kind of like a
massive membership dump
um it's we've i've been advised by legal
and accounting council it's just safer i
don't want to make myself a target by
advertising how big the discount is
so my ask to you is very soft
sell we primarily depend on people who
get memberships
why because youtube revenue twitch
revenue facebook revenue they're very
unpredictable
example january 1st youtube revenue
dropped 40
why because advertisers tend to spend
very little at the beginning of the year
and a lot at the end
so the ads that were much more
profitable
in q4 down 40 i have no control
sorry i froze there i have no control
over that whatsoever similar thing on
facebook since facebook's ad program is
smaller 70
down so when you sign up on my website
we don't care about any of that stuff
it's a it's a direct relationship as i
like to say
um and on today's bonus show producer
pat
tells his story about maskless
encounters in the deep south
that's all i'm going to say i don't want
to say anything else maskless
encounters in the deep south on today's
bonus show from producer pat super super
exciting
okay um i think trump has
landed or almost let's listen
oh my god okay so i think we're going to
hear from trump pretty soon it did seem
as though his plane landed
my pillow guys in his pitch now on right
side broadcasting so that means we're
probably going to be getting
very very close okay dennis o'neil says
you stink
thanks for the five bucks
naom and dale says do you think biden
will push a process to limit the potus
pardoning power could that be a
bipartisan effort why does potus have
such power
i think it would be very difficult to
limit pardon power in any real way
it would be very very difficult david
can you do a segment on the mass
evictions happening in wisconsin and the
rest of the country yes
i will it looks like they are bringing
the presidential seal
up which suggests we're probably getting
pretty close to prompt
yeah during biden's speech today he said
he will send out 2000 immediately if
democrats win georgia tomorrow oh yeah
i'd need to know more about it i don't
know what legal mechanism he's planning
on doing
uh using infobomb is just the senators
doing dumb stuff they already said they
were doing and have no ability to effect
on the votes
no ability to have effect on the votes
yes i agree with you
nothing's going to happen i don't know
what people think is going to happen on
wednesday
nothing's going to happen on wednesday
reminder if you have an oh this is an
important service announcement
reminder if you have amazon prime you
have a
free subscription on twitch even if you
don't use twitch
if it's going spare this guy
if it's going spare this guy i don't
know what that means
but it is true that if you have an
amazon prime subscription you can
subscribe to me for free on twitch prime
and you're just taking money from jeff
bezos and redirecting
redirecting it to the show all right
that's all i know about it
please have the eggman on as a guest i
would be interested in that
i would be interested david has gotten
so big trump isn't intentionally
starting late because he heard david was
streaming and wanted to force david to
stretch out of spite sad
that may be true that may be true yeah
which is crazy the trump last rally for
kelly leftover and the chicken purdue
exactly i wonder why the podium is
covered in such a strange way remember
this is the lectern the podium is this
thing that everybody that that they
stand on
this is the lectern very important and
this is the teleprompter
which of course joe biden and barack
obama and hillary clinton are terrible
people for using
that's trump's teleprompter if you were
wondering
all right i believe we are getting very
very close here
to the trump rally arguably his last
rally as president
david missed my chat all right let me
look for it my girlfriend
and i are watching and we both love the
hairstyle
keep being sexy mr eggplant oh my god
that is edgy
that is edgy wow aggressive
um david that color looks great on you
thank you
i i appreciate that
okay um
it now is very clear that donald trump's
plane
has landed or is about to land
photographers are getting into position
and uh this is gonna be bonkers let's
listen a little bit
[Music]
okay so it's uh it's sort of happening
and
maybe sometime soon um and we are going
to hear from donald trump i wish we
could get a side shot everybody clearly
looking you know sort of off that way
something must be going on we don't know
what um
but we will be opening phone lines after
this i want to hear from you
i will be live tomorrow night with
georgia election results
and then i will be live at 1 pm eastern
on wednesday
with the official counting of the
electoral vote
in a joint session of the house and
senate
okay very very important stuff that is
wednesday but we still have tonight and
we have tomorrow night's stream and we
will know a lot
a lot a lot about who will control the
senate
i guess we will know although the races
are expected to be very close it could
take days
to know the results uh we we may know
quite a bit
by 6 p.m wednesday about the future of
this country
david lee says i missed his super chat
let's see david lee
think democrats are going to win this
one they will turn out in force to try
and give biden a government he can work
with and republicans probably will stay
away to punish
the republicans for deserting trump all
right
uh thank you for the input let's see
i guess the plane still hasn't landed
but it is about to land
donald trump arriving for what will be
his
uh i believe last rally as president of
the united states
big thank you we just got out of nowhere
49 49 more twitch subs
which puts us at 207
and then i also have website members to
thank
um royce nord has just signed up at
joinedpakman.com
mason pramod linda mckee
amanda farrar leonard mitchell
matt biddart
ariana avina loretta
nelms reyes steven storm
oh it's the chopper and rubina nyan
that is an additional eight putting us
at
215. thank you so much thank you so much
i really do appreciate that
and you know what we're counting patreon
today
i'm feeling i'm feeling uh crazy about
it
glenn condren just pledged at
patreon.com
david pakman show we're gonna count it
it's a plus one
we are absolutely counting that i
appreciate that trump's last rally as
president but his first rally as
dictator says dead marine
is the flag to the left stained on one
of the long white stripes sad
i didn't see it we'll have to wait until
they uh put it back up
david can you please do a segment on
climate change is not a cost it's a
profitable investment called renewable
energy
uh thanks invest in humans i will look
into that
atheist someone that has no visib no
invisible means of support
that's an interesting definition have i
considered that the repeater is actually
trump himself their vocabulary is
shockingly similar
fair point this is the smallest trump
rally i've
seen in a very long time um
it seems similar to the ones that he was
doing before the election no i don't
know that it's particularly small
if they do not certify on the sixth and
take more than 10 days will pelosi be
sworn in as
president um yes maybe but
it's not going to happen it's just not
going to happen
and thanks to telltale for the super
chat love the show david very much
appreciate that
uh okay how are things looking people
are pointing out that there's no masks
here i haven't been looking are people
wearing masks
i thought that it from what i read this
was a mask required
event
did anybody see if there were masks i
wasn't even paying attention oh
everybody's saying very few
very few or none i don't know what we're
looking at right now but we'll have to
see
there were some people with masks
there are no masks one in 20 not a
single one
all right well seems like people are not
exactly in agreement if you're just
joining us please do not adjust your
screen
we um are just waiting donald trump has
landed in a helicopter
and we'll be speaking momentarily okay
we have
72 hours of streams coming up for you
like you would not believe these may be
the busiest 72
hours of streams we've ever had on our
channel all right
so what you can do to be notified when
we go live tomorrow with georgia
election results and when we go live on
wednesday
with the um accounting of the electoral
ballot is if you're watching on youtube
just hit subscribe it's free you're not
going to get spam emails
i don't get any information about you
i'm not able to do anything
other than youtube is more likely to
suggest my videos to you and when we go
live it'll show up prominently
in your youtube app or home page alright
so there's 30
000 beautiful people watching on youtube
this is a perfect time to hit that
subscribe
button twitch guys i'm not even gonna
make an ask on twitch people on twitch
know what to do
i don't even need to ask you know what
to do on twitch all right very very
exciting stuff um and hi to people
watching on facebook as well
i don't want to ignore the 2 000 people
2 000 people watching on
facebook so we are getting very close
to a rally here um
i don't know who any of these people are
anybody recognize some of these people
um
a lot of photographers and just a lot a
lot of nonsense going on
and here is a vehicle i guess a
motorcade so i guess trump got a ride
to via helicopter and then now what are
they listening to
ever they want total control that's
david perdue right
jobs and our economy with higher taxes
and more regulations
they want to allow illegal immigrants to
vote well really exciting
explosive delivery it just really
inspires okay
um russell says
i love you arja i guess that must be
your significant other i want a tv that
big in my house happy new year david two
bucks for tacos
are you out of the country to avoid what
might come absolutely
looks like a coveted breeding ground to
me this trump rally is such a total
clown show he lost i'm in a quote from
the movie joker you get what you deserve
i want to hear repeaters girlfriend i
know that the elections for south
carolina are over but do you think you
can investigate how many ballots graham
had thrown out because i think harrison
actually won
it's not there's no real way i can
investigate that unfortunate
tim says you are the only reason i'm
watching this rally whatever you do
don't shut up during it your voice is
more palatable than his well
we're gonna listen to trump we're going
to listen to him this is his last rally
after all
um as president i believe so
who are these people does anybody know
who these people are
okay i i just don't know it's weird
oh purdue is quarantined right perdue
can't be here because he's quarantined
that's that's still going on right i
believe that that's true
okay we're getting very very close very
very close let me get a final update
um we just had an additional 44 people
sign up via twitch sub putting us at
260.
i didn't think we were going to make it
to 306 but we actually might
big thank you to shanika giscombe for
signing up at joinedpakman.com
zach retzer has signed up on my website
john sittler has signed up
and then firebird has pledged via
patreon putting us at
264 an unbelievable number
an unbelievable number and uh
it could oh my god the ten more just
come in and one in in one second ten
more people signed up hold on
christopher crewer jared musculti
elia dinkle
roy gatt tamara bowling
giorgio di paolo and robin weiss
wow that that happened very quickly i
don't even understand i don't know that
our website can even keep up with what's
taking place right now
oh okay so i guess was the first
helicopter the
the decoy or not the decoy of a sort of
a decoy but bringing other people
and now trump's doing a fl this is crazy
what's going on i think trump might just
be leaving
no this is one of trump's patriotic
flyovers that's what this is
and um they're pretty pretty toxic i'm
not gonna lie
pretty damn toxic if you're just joining
us we are
standing by for donald trump
um more helicopters are showing up
and the rally scheduled to start
now looks like they do have school buses
waiting so that they're not going to
leave people out in the cold as they've
done before
after these events don't know how cold
it is there
uh there is another helicopter coming in
multiple helicopters coming in
all right uh
the camera work leaves a little
something to be desired not gonna lie
here's another helicopter coming in
and we will soon be hearing from donald
trump
uh okay other super chats coming in let
me see what we've got here
um hold on where did i leave off
i don't wanna i'm trying not to miss
people
david look at all those unmasked germ
spreaders thoughts and laughs on jovan
hutton pulitzer's testimony on georgia
voter fraud
i i didn't see it i don't know what it
is i can't even keep up
david the lens is doing magic people
look teeny behind stage during setup
they're not that bunched up and it's not
a huge crowd
fair okay i think trump will spend the
next four years condemning the
republican party splitting them in two
i'm hoping it'll result in their end
that's a dream scenario for the left
yeah south dakota here come take our
governor yeah you guys have a doozy you
guys have
a beauty as trump would say hunter sends
two dollars for drinks
derrick says they even made the lectern
remove its mask sad was hoping for a
clint eastwood talking to a chair moment
edwin says i'm a bit surprised he's not
landing his chopper right beside the
pulpit and scream that would be even
more trump-like
um oh you know what i want to do i saw
two people
uh in chat ask me about what books i've
been reading
lately um i'll tell you let me give you
a couple recommendations
i know i know some people in the
audience are like reading what are you
talking about david
i read a lot so let me give you some
recommendations i
recently uh read this book right here
the silent patient by alex michaelities
very quick read it is best seller type
stuff
actually instant new york times
bestseller yeah
it's not it's it's a very quick read
very enjoyable really it's just a great
it's a quick nice novel to just read
very very exciting stuff
i recommend it i'm also uh hold on
kim stanley robinson i just
got this book delivered kim stanley
robinson's
of the ministry for the future excellent
reviews elliott pepper who's an author i
like
highly recommended this to me and uh oh
one of barack obama's favorite books of
2020 oh i think it was on obama's list
i look forward to reading this i'm also
in the middle
of um the three californias this is a
trilogy these were
three books written by kim stanley
robinson
wow people are going to bail because i'm
talking about books but i'm going to do
it
he wrote these three novels all taking
place in california they're all
different um in the early 80s
late 80s and 1990 i've read the first
two
starting the third one and then i also
read the first book of the mars
trilogy by kim stanley robinson really
really good stuff
and then for non-fiction i recently read
this book the hot zone by richard
preston
about the history of ebola ebola
is what's called a phylo virus philo
referring to sort of like
string because they they look like
string marburg
ebola zaire and ebola i believe it's
sudan are the three sort of initial
strains
and then in the book there's the the
sort of discovery of the
i believe it's the restin strain of
ebola
uh really really good really maybe not
the best thing to read during a pandemic
but i can't recommend the book uh
the the book more highly and yes i read
books guys i'm sorry i lost
how sad is it i lost 1500 viewers during
the time i talked about books
i lost 1500 on youtube but i gained 300
on twitch while talking about books
don't know what that tells us don't know
what that tells us
all right it is finally finally time
as another helicopter pulls up
for us to hear from donald trump this
could go for hours
this could i have this could be fidel
castro like
um so we should be ready for something
really nuts
really really really nuts big thank you
to the 21 folks who just grabbed twitch
subs putting us at 292
we may be at 306 we actually may be at
306
on joinpakman.com
robert suco signed up robert stallings
signed up ben weinberg signed up joseph
rembe
signed up catherine brandis is a new
member that's five
jason hamburg is number six gilbert
daniel number seven tracy euler
number eight michael cowdell is number
nine
linda collier is number 10 putting us
at 302 and with an
insanely generous gift of 20
subscriptions on twitch
by odw c
uh we are now at hold on a second what
is happening
30 302 we are at 332
subs and memberships during this stream
i can't believe it it's it's we've only
been live an hour
332 it is stunning
stunning and many people excited i guess
to uh see off donald trump his last
rally
the marines opening the doors
to trump's thing
and we are going to hear from donald
trump very very soon
nerd archie says have you had yang on
yet you know i had yang on before
anybody else
we had him on two or three times he
doesn't respond to our emails anymore
it's sad
i think andrew yang i mean i'm not
really kidding when i say this i think
andrew yang has gotten too big for the
david pakman show
there's prump um we don't hear back from
him he's too famous now to do the show
i would love it if he came back on
oof i'm seeing the use of the word gunt
oh god that's very very aggressive very
very aggressive let's listen
[Music]
yep so they're going with the uh the
ruse that trump likes country music
um trump needs to read viktor frankl
man's search for meaning
excellent book velma beautiful beautiful
suggestion
absolutely beautiful suggestion ministry
for the future is the most
important book of the year and i spam
comments about it the most important
parts can't be discussed on youtube
i'm telling you i have not been looking
forward to reading a book
this much for a while ministry of the
future
by uh kim stanley robinson
this is not a man who reads that we're
about to hear from and you're going to
be able to tell
um by listening to him speak that he is
not
a man who reads with any regularity
that's not a value judgment
it's just a statement of fact my friends
just a statement of fact
uh let me get these last thank yous in
1206 that 6
15 is another 21
putting us at 353
[Music]
wait hold on 332 353 yeah 353
and let's see if i can thank everybody
else here
uh oh i only have one person to thank
eric talbot
eric talbot new member 354 today
and i don't know that i've ever seen
donald trump look more orange
let's listen okay we'll keep we'll stay
muted on the music just to avoid any
you know possible copyright issues but i
so appreciate you joining me
i am going to be live tomorrow night
with georgia election results
finally we will get half a step closer
to knowing who will control the senate
tomorrow
um oof really bad i mean listen i don't
know much about makeup but
i know you're supposed to blend it a
little more than that holy [ __ ]
um tomorrow night georgia election
results wednesday we will be
live live live with the official
electoral vote count so
please make sure you are subscribed on
youtube and following on twitch
because i do want to see you here
tomorrow night and then again on
wednesday
trump's hands are completely different
trump's hands look like they belong to a
different person
well i want to thank you very much hello
georgia by the way
thanks christine there's no way we lost
georgia there's no way
it's starting already we'll fight again
and you'll see what's going to happen
we'll talk about it and
uh i just want to thank you this is some
crowd you know
you're going to need volume they had 14
people in three cars
no there was no way and i just want to
thank you
oh we're gonna we're gonna miss this
when it's over my friend both of them
it's amazing
and
and i actually did much better on the
second one
it's great to be back in this incredible
state the home of hard-working patriots
who believe in god
family and country very sick man very
very sick
tomorrow each of you is going to vote in
one of the most important runoff
elections of the history of our country
so he is saying vote
runoff one of the most important
elections
really it's really not runoff it's
elections because
uh it's a biggie our country is
depending on you the whole world is
watching the people of georgia tomorrow
and you got to swamp them because
everything's so crooked around
i mean not and not here they were saying
oh he's complaining about georgia no no
i'm complaining about eight different
i should be wearing a heart rate monitor
doing this on screen so you can see
what's happening we're going to get
everyone you know you're going to show
up at the polls in record numbers you
got to swamp them and together we're
going to defeat
the democratic streamers and deliver and
thundering
victory to david perdue and wiz david
david david
we love our david i know he's in
quarantine respected
and loved by him it's too much has
really been a star
in washington kelly leffler where is
kelly
she's gone
where is our kelly what a job you've
done
thank you and we'll tell you about kelly
[Applause]
what are they saying
tribal trump
kelly fights for me david fights for me
that i can tell you
cry more trump what and i will also
say you know the republicans you have to
understand for the people that don't
fight not for me fighting for us
because we have a lot of corrupt things
that happen
when they don't fight one thing i've
learned about republicans i have
some difficulties but you know a
difficulty that they don't have
they never forget they never forget and
people are going to find that out
because
uh we have to go and we have to go all
the way and that's what's happening and
you watch what happens over the next
couple of weeks you watch what's going
to come out watch what's going to be
revealed
and i have to tell you that the stakes
in this election
could not be higher true you vote
tomorrow you want to go out tomorrow
people want to go out they don't want to
do the
the ballot thing and they don't want to
do it unless it's the other side in
which case they just print them out
they don't want to do it they want to go
and vote and make sure your vote is
counted
make sure they don't let you say i'm
sorry somebody else has already voted
for you
your vote tomorrow will decide which
party controls the united states senate
the radical democrats are trying to
capture georgia's senate seats
so they can wield unchecked unrestrained
absolute power
over every aspect of your lives
who even believes this crap if the
liberal democrats take the senate of the
white house and they're not taking this
white house we're going to fight like
hell
[Laughter]
it's actually sad like it's very
interesting
i have no reaction to it anymore because
it's so over it's just like what it's
just a crazy guy yelling at a cloud
you lose you lose you go and you go
wherever you're going and you go
and say maybe i'll do it again sometime
or maybe i won't or i'll get back to
life
but when you win in a landslide and they
ride
and it's rigged it's not acceptable
[Applause]
then you have a a country that would be
run
if these two don't win and if we don't
take the presidency you have a country
that would be run by schumer pelosi and
biden
moderate democrats oh okay the people of
georgia will be at the mercy of the
left-wing socialist
communist marxist name one where it's
going you know we don't like to use the
name one word communist how about the
press look at them back there look at
all of them
how about the press non-sequitur
oh boy that's a lot of press but you
know
they've gone silent now they have a new
thing they used to fight me left right
i'd go they'd go you know you'd fight
i'd win that one who knows who wins
but people would hear well when you're
missing for two months there's nothing
to talk about say something bad about
you
they don't want to talk about it so if
we talk about certain subjects that
you've been watching over the last six
months
all of a sudden they were getting
clobbered so they when told
stone cold silent big tech
the fake news media they go silence
anymore they don't talk about it
and that is the beginning of communism
that's exactly what happens
[Applause]
not really i think they hate our country
and they despise
georgia values and i think a lot of you
despise them as you know
there's nothing tormenting hate
democrats will not do
to get power that they so desperately
crave even the outright
stealing of elections like they're
trying to do
with us we're not going to let it happen
over the past
and i hope mike pence comes through for
us oh my god
pence can't do anything vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us
hence his role is merely symbolic on
wednesday through
i won't like him quite as much wow now
mike is a great guy he's a he's a he's a
wonderful man and a
smart man and a man that i like a lot
but he's going to have a lot to say
about it and he you know one thing with
him
you're going to get straight shots he's
going to call it straight
over the past few weeks we've
demonstrated that we won the election in
a landslide almost
75 million people voted for me
but how many voted for biden the most of
any incumbent president in the history
of our country
this is a mind virus guys it's a mind
virus
close to 12 million more votes in 2016
one of the largest actually the single
largest
increase in the history of our country
no person
that won went to a second term or went
through an election
where he got nearly 12 million votes
no it never happened before nothing
happened
totally unintelligible gains among
african-americans hispanic americans
asian-americans
and we won the largest share of
non-white vote
of any republican president in 60 years
we also wanted this ivanka back here how
sad
the counties now when you win just a few
bellwether counties
don jr mark meadows maybe we won 18 out
of 19 that's a record
and they said we didn't win we won 25
of 26 toss-up house races
and i think we have one that we're
waiting for right did you see the one in
hello mike how are you mike did you see
the one in
new york where claudia good woman they
keep finding votes
they keep finding about she's up by 18.
oh we just found 19 votes
that's uh same kind of stuff democrats
delusional to gain
15 house seats and instead and
kevin mccarthy gives us the credit good
man
very good man my coattails we swept
our republican house candidates to
victory we have a couple of great ones
with us tonight
and the democrats lost 14 seats it was
supposed to be the other way around
what how does this relate no president
loses unless they play games and you
don't lose they play games the fact is
we won the presidential election we want
it big
and we're going to win tomorrow we're
going to win it really big we have to
have no idea how important that is
tonight our mission here in georgia
is to make sure the radical f cannot rob
you of your voice
and your votes in washington you can't
lose these two people
who's trying to rob them of their voice
their it's republicans who have said
maybe stay home because it's rigged
they do have a voice and they love their
state and they love their
country the democrats are trying to
steal the white house
you cannot let them you just can't let
them
steal the us senate you can't let it
happen
they won the white house can't let it
happen david and kelly
are running against the most extreme
liberal candidates in the history of
your state
probably in the history of our country
of the world
and rafael warnock never been anyone
more liberal
well you know i beat ossoff once
running against a very fine woman karen
who you know
and uh he was at 57 and i got involved
we drove him down to 49 and then he
ended up in runoff
and she ended up winning now i have to
beat him a second time and this is going
to be hopefully easy
because raphael when you know what
warnock stands for
it really should be easy cast deciding
votes to rubber stamp
the agenda of aoc and bernie sanders
crazy burning stacey abrams what's with
his stacy abrams
what does that even mean as a senator he
would rubber stamp the agenda of a
georgia official that's weird
petrified of stacey abrams
what's that all about did you see this
consent decree they signed
with signature verification you can
forget about it
what they have done to your state i
think most people have no idea what
they've done to your state
that consent decree are these two people
all republicans in charge
i don't know they say they're
republicans
i really don't think they are they can't
oh
no true scotsman like if we want to have
a special session
because your legislature's excellent
they want to have us
why wouldn't they let us have a special
session if they want to check
signatures in fulton counties signages
you think the crowd knows about a
special session who cares about it first
and then we'll do fulton they do cop
then they never get the phone why
wouldn't they do that why wouldn't they
do that that's a positive thing anyway
the democrats want to turn america
i'll be hearing about amorica trump's
coming out very positive
from the standpoint of negative
i shouldn't say this i shouldn't say
this because no please do
i just don't want you to tell anybody
outside of this room other than the
millions of people
no but you know i endorsed him he was in
last place
and i endorsed him he went to first
place very like immediately and then he
won the
primary and then i gave him a couple of
rallies which i don't like doing for
other people i was telling kevin i had
to do
rallies for other people i'd do them for
me right he's miserable to be here even
not that easy a crowd like this they say
over 25 000 people
over what over a couple of days notice
and is everybody glad you're here right
i think so depends how long you're gonna
talk bro
there is no place like a trump rally but
you know what this is a kelly rally and
a david rally
and i wouldn't do it unless i loved them
both you might want to talk about them
at some point but i'm going to be here
in a year and a half
and i'm going to be campaigning against
your governor and your crazy secretary
of state
republican crowd cheers against
republican officials candidates they
want to
turn the democrats do america into
venezuela
with no jobs no prosperity no rights no
freedom
no future no rights you and your family
here is exactly what the radical left
will do if they win
this runoff election which we can't let
them do tomorrow tomorrow's a big day i
guess we have to get
over a million votes tomorrow right
kelly over a million
all right that's a lot of votes kelly
but we'll do it
and the one thing i know if they win
i'll get no credit
and if they lose they're going to blame
trump these people
and kelly won't let that i don't plan on
saying much about trump one way or the
other about
in terms of these races it's gonna be a
great story
it's a great story a very important
story for our country long beyond
georgia for our country it's such a big
story
they'll massively raise your taxes on
the middle class to pay
for socialism rich people will pay three
percentage points more
we've totally rebuilt the us military
much of it coming right out of
georgia
you built it right out of georgia a lot
of it you have incredible
contractors in georgia military
contractors and they got plenty of our
money
spent 2.5 trillion dollars when i took
over the military it was absolutely a
mess it was
that's not true depleted now it's the
opposite of depleted the u.s
military will be gutted military
families across the street
and all over the state will be betrayed
their benefits and opportunities will be
slashed
fort benning fort gordon and other
georgia military institutions will be
the first on the chopping block they
came to me they said
sir we have no bullets we couldn't kill
anybody if we had to generations of
american patriots
trained to win two world wars i don't
know
fort benning let's see give me a couple
of names i could give you some
i don't want to give them the credit but
you'll name them you'll name them after
other people for trump yeah how about
that i like that
yeah let's change today let's change it
kelly
let's change it if they name it trump
let's change it now now they're going to
go back and say
he wants to have fort benning change no
one cares
trump is still overstating the
importance of the things he says
fort benning to be changed no no i don't
want that
the democrats will surrender the entire
u.s manufacturing industry to
china there it is you notice they never
criticized
china right they never could it's russia
russia russia i saw it today again
russia russia oh russia
here we go that was another great scam
i've been involved in the two greatest
scams in american history oh he's been
involved in more than two
and now they are trying to steal an
election from us and we won
not by a little bit we won in numbers
like nobody's seen before
if us often won does he really believe
that do you guys think he believes
real and you know what's going to happen
they'll throw
open american borders and allow tens of
millions of illegal
immigrants to pour into our country from
every corner of the globe
your schools your hospitals and your
communities will be overwhelmed
and the wall the wall the wall remember
we'll build the wall we're gonna build
the wall and that's right mexico is
paying for the wall remember the promise
was a full wall by january 20th
full wall by january 20th points and uh
they were paying for the wall
they paid for 28 000 troops along the
wall and along the border which we don't
need so much anymore
none of that's true they built almost
500 miles of wall
and they want to rip down the wall they
want to rip down that's why the numbers
have been so great but now everyone's
coming back up because they think this
guy's going to win
and if he wins it's going to be uh
everything that they could dream for
dream so wait how are people getting
through now
just because biden won if there's a wall
i don't get it
to do it so they're coming up now the
caravans remember the caravans the
caravans are starting to form here they
come
but uh let's uh let's keep this thing
going we have great support
in congress we have good support in the
senate i wouldn't say great
could be better but people will remember
the people that don't support us
right if they win this race
democrats will implement nationwide
catch and release you know what that is
you catch a criminal
and you take his name you say you're
released into our country
you catch a criminal and you take his
name like in marriage that's weird
hey whatever happened to jared solving
the israeli-palestinian conflict we're
not hearing much about that
just don't show up and turn our that's
when i had the big debate with biden
they come back for court i said no they
don't
i turned out to be right did they
apologize i don't think so
and turn our entire country into one
giant sanctuary for criminal aliens
setting loose tens of thousands of
dangerous offenders and putting
ms-13 gang members straight into your
children's schools
and you know we've removed thousands and
thousands of
ms-13 gang members it doesn't really
feel like a rally energy
i want to thank border patrol and i want
to thank our great law enforcement
incredible people they're incredible
[Music]
and the people that understand those
values are kelly and david
they understand those values yikes
you're with our law enforcement
right that's 100 i don't have to ask you
that
they'll allow heroin cocaine fentanyl
and other deadly drugs to flood across
our borders again oh they won't poison
our youth
that's so different they'll eliminate
private insurers we have 180 million
people that love their private insurers
you can forget about it
and you'll lose your doctor remember
president obama said
you can keep your doctor you can keep
your plan guess what he said it 28 times
that was a lie is there anything trump
won't lie about turned out to be a big
great scam lie
i can't think of anything i got rid of
the individual mandate the most
unpopular thing in obamacare
fighting a lot of different fronts which
really doesn't make it obamacare anymore
by the way
they'll resume the war on christians and
attack catholic organizations like
little sisters of the poor
they will ban voter id we want voter id
is that so much to end
an institute universal
unsolicited maryland balloting in every
state
unsolicited they will never be i'll
tell you this if we don't do something
fast there will never be another fair
election
in america you know ever we're known for
elections and now we're
being left out all over the world about
this last election
and you've got to swarm it tomorrow now
the good thing about tomorrow it's one
state so you have a lot of eyeballs
watching it's
ah when you have 50 states and they do
it
to various various states i never said
they like it
you know i was leading in pennsylvania
by here we go hundreds of thousands of
votes all of a sudden i was tired i said
what happened
right they'll make washington dc and
other liberal places
the 51st 52nd 53rd states of the union
guarantees beautiful
the radical left a permanent majority of
the u.s senate and the house
and the electoral college it will make
it really a
one party country and the party will be
the wrong party
they will pack the supreme court with
craig's extremists
right unlike trump with the supreme
court they are not
stepping up to the plate they're not
stepping up
you mean stealing the election for you
how about that
that's radical we don't have look at the
supreme court
president of the united states i want to
file suit
i want to do and they said sir you can't
you really can't do that well
sir so they have legal reasons
complex legal rights called the law of
the united states and you get defrauded
out of an election
you should be able to file a suit but we
can't do that
what a complainant sir you don't have
standing how about that
i'm the president seven
states you know i was winning by a lot
and then all of a sudden i was losing by
a little tiny bit
so far oh this guy's gonna do the kind
of numbers we're gonna miss this guy
right i mean to some degree we're gonna
miss the insanity
they say i don't have standing to bring
us in what kind of a legal system is
that
but the supreme court has let us down so
far
who knows maybe they'll come back maybe
they'll come back they'll pack the
supreme court with crazed extremists
then they'll be saying you know i should
have done something about this
when they start having 24 25 26 justices
they want to have the justices rotate to
the lowest courts
so they'll rotate these nine justices
will have a great time
rotating but they're bent on destroying
our constitution
silence on that one america's founding
if the left wins these senate seats they
will abolish
the senate you know this the filibuster
they will knock it out all i've been
saying to be honest with you for a long
time they're going to do that at some
point they're going to do that
and why don't we do it first i said it
if they're going to do it you might as
well do it first and now everybody said
you were right
but you know what i want to be wrong
because i want these two to win
because if they win we don't want to do
it it's a bad thing for our country
if trump's right i don't want to be
right that would give them the power to
ram through every deluded piece of
left-wing legislation
that they've ever wanted that they've
ever dreamt of the the crowd being
completely silent is actually funny
second amendment will be gone your
borders and great new wall will be gone
your police departments will be gone as
we know them and your life savings will
be gone
will be like a large-scale version of so
many other countries that you look at
that are poverty america as you know it
will be over
and it will never i believe be able
to come back again it'll be too far gone
your vote tomorrow could lose and it
could be
your last chance to save the america
that we love that's why i'm here i don't
want to do rallies for other people i
told you
you really get the sense that the crowd
is just not engaged with
any of this nonsense our left wants to
destroy
our country demolish our history and
erase
everything that we hold dear this could
be the most important vote
you will ever cast for the rest of your
life it really could be this is
so important i mean think of it it's so
important it's amazing actually that
in one state you have two races
simultaneously i don't think a thing
like that's ever happened before
if you don't show up the radical
democrats well when a lot of people say
oh well trump maybe he wants it that way
no
you know what i want i want a great
country i want these two very special
people to be elected and i want to be
clear you know if those of you that
know how badly screwed we got i want to
be clear
that we can't let that happen again we
can't let that happen again
we're going to come back and i really
believe we're going to take
what they did to us on november 3rd
we're going to take it back
but these two people they can't go
through this
what does he mean they're going
if you don't go and vote the socialist
of marxists
will be in charge of our country if you
don't fight to save your country with
everything you have
you're not going to have a country left
i love this state this state's been very
good to me we've had a lot of victories
in this state just had one on november
3rd actually
and i love the people of this state we
can't let that happen
the damage they do will be permanent and
will be
irreversible can't let it happen
nothing and no one will be able to stop
them these senate seats are
truly the last line
of defense now i must preface that by
saying because they'll say he just
conceded
no no i don't think so we know you're
not conceding so kelly if i might add
[Applause]
i think we're going to win in which case
will be the last line of defenses called
veto
vito vito vito corleone
so tomorrow you must get out and vote
for david perdue and kelly lefler
over the last four years david perdue
has been one of our greatest allies and
strongest offenders in washington he's a
great gentleman david was a critical
vote and the right to
pass the largest package of tax cuts and
reforms in american history we did that
together we got it done
launching an incredible economic boom
the greatest tax cuts in the history of
our country thanks don
okay thank you restrictions we were so
restricted we couldn't breathe in this
country that's one of the big i think it
might have been more important in many
ways
than the tax cuts right and toilet
flushing great businessmen of our world
right
i think it was maybe more important when
georgia needed
a strong voice in washington after
hurricane michael remember hurricane
michael and i was down here with david
but david perdue led the charge to get
the workers and farmers of your
state the relief you deserved he said
sir can we get a billion dollars trump
can
never sounds less genuine than when he's
praising other people
who aren't there because they're
praising trump if that makes sense
i've never seen before came in from a
location that is just very unique it was
a horrible thing i was here for a long
time with david and he worked and he
and his uh his kin you know is kin the
great sonny perdue or
department of agriculture our secretary
are they related what does that mean
i didn't know they were related we
worked very hard and we got the farmers
and the businesses the money that they
had to have and now they're thriving
david has also been one of the most
courageous advocates fighting for
immigration did anybody check that's
american workers american wages
american families and american jobs he
led
the effort in congress to build the wall
that's right
and kelly helped on that she's a little
bit newer
to the senate but she helped a lot those
last moments you were there without you
it wouldn't have happened actually
crack down cousins okay interesting in
chain migration an institute on parallel
protection
for our great citizens he fought to help
us replace nafta disaster
with the brand new usmca they said it
couldn't be done a giant victory for
georgia
for workers and for farmers all over our
country
nafta was the worst trade deal probably
ever signed
and that maybe has to exist usmca is
very similar i i cut for some reason i
love it when he says gantry argan tree
firm nearly 300 federal judges
we have a record on federal judges and
three supreme court justices
which is a tremendous thing we have
almost 300 federal judges
committed to interpreting our
constitution
as written no one fights harder they're
running out of gas
of georgia then david perdue david's
opponent
john ossoff is an unhinged radical
leftist
he's not a senator you're going to call
him a jew also that'd be that'd be the
next thing
just to just go straight anthony said
that he's very proud to be endorsed by
socialist crazy bernie sanders he's weak
on china he promoted chinese propaganda
and then he failed to disclose his
business ties to the chinese communist
party
other than that he's a wonderful guy
right asof supports the largest tax hike
in american history if they get in
warnock
and also if they get in you're gonna
have the largest tax increase
that you've ever had no i think it'll
just go back to before trump
country for what the green new deal
let's rip down a building because its
windows are too big let's build a
building with no windows
among many other things no toilets
what's the insane green new deal
middle class parents trying to raise a
family
he will support the socialist takeover
of american health care
which will lead to rationing poverty and
death
assaf also backed the radical left-wing
crusade to defund police
the last summer he proudly joined the
anti-police mob he didn't like the
police he doesn't like our police
i don't think ossoff's ever called for
defunding can anybody fact check
slandering our brave men and women in
blue
if you vote for john ossoff he will
attack our heroes he will destroy our
economy
and he will betray you and your family
and it'll happen
very quickly that's why you must vote
and really importantly get out tomorrow
vote for david perdue he's a great
gentleman he loves you
georgia has another fantastic champion
in senator kelly lefler kelly is a
staunch defender of our
vile woman incredible military i'm so
proud of our military she supports the
wall
and she always stands with the heroes of
law enforcement
ice and border patrol i hated it kelly
when we got ballots in from the military
with trump all over it
and they got thrown into a river you saw
that
they threw ballots into a river from the
military with my name all over we want
trump
boom goes into the river oh god this is
one of many instances of problem kelly
is also a committed protector of your
second amendment rights
with kelly's vote we confirmed our third
new supreme court justice amy coney
barrett
working with david kelly helped rescue
the u.s economy from the china virus
passing nearly 4 trillion in economic
relief saving over 1.5 million
georgia jobs and rescuing countless
small businesses all across your state
businesses that now are doing really
well and you know we also
came up with a vaccine nobody else would
have done that they would have done that
in 10 years
what kelly and david also both strongly
support my efforts to provide
two thousand dollar stimulus checks to
hard-working americans
do they because i don't remember them
saying that my reasoning is simple i
mean we're
conservative with money but my reasoning
is simple
you didn't cause this problem this
problem was caused by
china china kelly is running against a
hard left extremist named
rafael warlock
warnick is the most radical and
dangerous left-wing candidate ever to
seek this office
and certainly i'm pretty sure bernie's
significantly to warnock's left
i use warnock publicly declared his
support for socialism
and he once welcomed the anti-american
communist dictator fidel castro to his
church
i'm not a castro fan but that's also not
true he was a nice guy
warnick said that quote nobody can serve
both god
and the military a vicious smear against
thousands of patriotic service members
across the state of georgia he wants to
abolish cash bail you see how that's
working in new york city right
not working too well he has called for
quote opening up the jails
and he slandered our police officers as
gangsters
thugs and bullies the choice for the
voters of georgia could not be more
clear
john osoph on rap and rafael warlock
our fringe extremists who would wreck
everything georgia patriots
hold dear to their hearts kelly leffler
david people wondering how long this is
gonna go on it it could go on for hours
i was not kidding when i said that
it could be not that much longer this
could go on for another 90 minutes
they share your values
they want to defend your interest and
they will always put
america first did you see the other day
what a great name america first
they announced they don't want to do the
america first policy how crazy
even if you're not going to do it which
is basically protect us we come first
right
but even and that includes financially
in every other way
even if you don't believe it you don't
say we're going to end america first
they want to end america first kelly i'd
love you to just come up and say a few
words
this should be insane
hello georgia
wow inspiring i have an announcement
georgia
on january 6th i will object to the
electoral
college vote
that's right thank you this is so
stupid all right georgia but i have a
very important question for you
are you ready to show america that
george is a red state
that's right that's right look this
president
fought for us we're fighting for him he
put america first
he put the american worker first
thank you mr president he stood with
me he restored our military
my opponent radical liberal robber
no he attacked yeah he attacked our
police
our military he spoke out against
israel evangelicals small businesses
georgia we have to hold the line you
have to get out and vote tomorrow
georgia i'm going to take this
opportunity to refill my water
we have to get it done i love you guys
thank you
god bless you god bless george
thank you kelly that was nice i'm glad i
invited her up
kelly i'm glad i invited you up that was
great thank you donna
that was so great
thank you thank you you know it really
is it's fight for our country it's
really fight for our country not fight
for trump it's fight for our country
because that's what we're finding
also joining us tonight are georgia
representatives
marjorie taylor green i love volunteers
come up here kelly wants you to come up
here come here
don't mess with her don't mess with her
absolutely hello
northwest georgia
all right let me tell you something i'm
so fired up to hear
senator kelly leffler she's going to
object on january
6th yeah
who on earth is this why i believe in
her you see when you have a strong
senator
kelly leffler from georgia fighting for
you
and fighting is this that marjorie
taylor green clown
this is why you have to turn out
tomorrow
right this woman's out of her mind yes
we have to save our senate set senate
seats we have to save america and stop
socialism this is the last line
we're gonna hand over our senate seats
to a pastor
who preaches abortion from the pulpit
the pulpit no
how is this even possible in a country
as rich as the united states
holding a bible in his hand
if anything go out there and vote for
the unborn tomorrow
right wow we've had enough
we're not going to let georgia go to two
radical
socialists neither is a socialist
i need you all to go out there and vote
our district
has to show up we've got to stop this
attack
stop our senate seats from being handed
over to these radicals
and we're going to fight for president
trump on january
6. he's very very sick very sick
god bless georgia god bless america
let's do this
disgusting
that woman's really really ill i also
want to introduce two great warriors
friends of mine
andrew clyde and jody heist jody thank
you
thank you andrew jody heist out of his
mind great job really
radical we have another friend of our
south carolina senator lindsey graham
oh no not
lindsay and mike lee is here too but i'm
a little angry at him today
where's mike lee a little angry at you
today but that's all
state representative vernon jones what a
great
a guy man and an early supporter of mind
who's also on
the ballot tomorrow public service
commissioner bubba
mcdonald right
strong supporter you're going to do
great
great guy thank you bubba thank you good
luck tomorrow
you'll do well georgia republican party
chairman
david shaffer and he's fighting he's out
there he is fighting
he is fighting by the way i also want to
say hello to
kelly's husband is one of the great
entrepreneurs in our country
he's respected by everybody he's a tough
guy but he is a sweetheart and he loves
your state i just want to say hello do
you mind
okay he doesn't want that he doesn't
want it but i will tell you he's
respected as a businessman respected by
everybody
and gives tremendous amounts of money to
charity and everything else thank you
very much
[Music]
sweetheart of a man a friend of mine and
you know i don't know what it is
i'm not so good with the bikes really
losing steam
maybe i stay away from a little bit but
chris cox is bikers for trump and he's
the founder
and he had more people show up for me
whenever i saw i'd go
to places i'd have two three four
thousand bikes
and secret service would go crazy i said
no
i'm so happy and they wouldn't do it for
any of them
secret service would go crazy they were
with me for whatever reason bikers like
me
and i like them boaters bikers
where's chris right i don't know why the
bikers like me chris but they do but i
like you guys a lot the
the curling community is reportedly very
radical right
then we'd be packed and we couldn't even
get them they didn't even want to be
inside they'd stood outside and they
were protecting their president when i
became president
i never felt safer in my life thank you
true that's true another man who's uh
respected by everybody friend of mine
david mcintosh
club for growth david
thank you dave not to be confused with
tim apple david macintosh is a different
guy
i want to thank don jr did he do a good
job tonight i watched
seem to be on something don is great
he sort of has they love our dawn
samantha golden delicious also will be
delivering the eulogy
uh after trump's presidency is dead
always been
incredible and i also uh
came with somebody who people like a lot
people like her a lot i don't know
she doesn't really like the concept of
running for
office she says what do i need it for
dad
oh no where's ivanka oh god
there she is yeah trump's desperate for
her to run for office
come on up here stand back and stand by
the slapping the lectern is really
annoying
wow
hello georgia oh my god it's cringy
already
it is so incredible to be back here
with so many amazing hard-working
georgia families who are
fighting for our children's future
totally each one of you
[Music]
and it's so great to be back in georgia
with this warrior my father
the people's president
this feels like a fake rally like like
uh
remember the jim carrey what was what's
that movie where jim carries on a tv
show and he doesn't know it
it's such a great movie and by his
side are two amazing
senators that we have to send
back to the senate and send a resounding
message that patriotism
is alive and well in georgia this is the
goya black beans woman right
and georgia is going to keep freedom
alive in america
please vote thank you god bless you god
bless georgia
and god bless america and god bless
our president
i'm sure she's referring to biden right
thank you ivanka thanks don kimberly
everybody thank you all
tomorrow our entire nation is counting
on the people of georgia
in a way the world is counting on the
people of georgia the fate of our
country is at stake it's in your hands
you must deliver a republican victory so
big that the democrats can't steal it or
cheat it away we have all
they'll be trying though i'll tell you
that we have all seen
what our opponents are capable of doing
i ran two elections i won both of them
second one much more successful dad come
on dude
but we can't let this happen any longer
on election night
we were leading by so much we're not
going to have that tomorrow we're not
going to have that tomorrow night
you're leading and then all of a sudden
boom it's gone like magic let's hope
it's just gone
florida and ohio in record numbers
we want iowa by 8.2 percent
nobody's ever won those three states
so he trusts those numbers that's almost
impossible unless
people do a lot of either get very lucky
or they cheat
we're up 293 000 votes
in michigan 112 000 votes in washington
in wisconsin we were way up 356 000
votes in georgia
356. no mention of the virus so far
other than china 100 000 votes in
pennsylvania
it was over i should have run up to the
podium and said thank you very much for
this wonderful victory
then maybe they wouldn't have had time
to close those
booths right the counting rooms and do
what they did
but then it all started to disappear and
i tell the story because we can't let
this happen
tomorrow kelly so keep your eyes open
since the election we have put forth
indisputable evidence documenting
the rampant fraud which will be
announced on wednesday as you know
why not announce it now
and i want to thank senator josh hawley
and ted cruz
and all of the incredible senators that
have stepped up to fight because they've
seen what happens they know it's a fraud
and not just here you know i watched
some of the people on fox i had no
choice i had no choice i had to
i didn't know why is he fighting for
georgia
it's not enough no i need three this is
live guys this is live
but six and we're going to win them all
but they said
they said why one of the people a very
fine woman actually but she said why is
he
fighting georgia it doesn't get him
there i said no but georgia
and pennsylvania and one other get me
there
and we have six and maybe eight if you
look at him
and we were leading all of them by a lot
until like
he lost two months ago he's figuring out
how to win now right here in georgia
there were tens of thousands of illegal
votes cast
and counted you know that and here are
just a few examples
watch this for tomorrow we're up
ten thousand three hundred and fifteen
ballots were cast by individuals
whose name and date of birth matches a
georgia resident
who died in 2020 prior to the
election then you're these are all lies
secretary of state said two people
two people now i don't know how many
people are on that list
but it's a lot of people check out my
tweet about this 506
ballots were cast by individuals whose
name in
date of birth matches an incarcerated
felon
that's this top one georgia prison these
are all lies
all there but they did a lot of work i
paid a lot of money to a lot of people i
can tell you that
four thousand five hundred and two
illegal ballots he's going right from
this by individuals who do not appear
on the state's voter rolls well that's
sort of strange
18 325 illegal ballots were cast
by individuals who registered to vote
using an address listed as vacant
according to the postal service at least
86
880 ballots were cast by people whose
registrations were illegally backdated
oh i can't believe that happened
these are all lies 66 000 votes you
don't have to understand we're down by
a little more than 11 000 so every one
of these
is determinative 66 000 votes in georgia
were cast by people under the legal
voting age at least fifteen thousand
ballots were cast by
individuals who moved out of the state
prior to the november third election and
maybe they moved back in i don't know i
mean i can't tell you
let's go back usually takes a little
time right you know
we moved out let's go back darling
george's absency ballot rejection rate
went from an average of three percent
in 2016 and
then went down very low to almost
zero now oh think of it almost zero
if you multiply that out and this is the
crowd
still there i mean it's it's silent
48 out of 159 counties in georgia
rejected
no ballots at all
these absentee ballot rejection rates
prove that the tens of thousands
of illegitimate ballots were counted
there were more absentee ballots in 2020
than ever before by four but magically
far fewer ballots were
rejected this alone is more than enough
to swing the election to us
whoops what the hell happened there
sorry about that this one that was great
i apologize i don't know what happened
there for individual
in all of the swing states now they'll
check this out and that's fine i hit the
wrong button sorry guys you take a look
at it officials
egregiously violated state laws in order
to solicit
facilitate and promote cheating and
theft on a scale
never seen before these crooked and
incompetent officials suspended
signature verification
i said i want you to go to fulton county
to check
the signatures because hundreds of
thousands of ballots came in
i want you to check the signature to see
if it could be
somebody that lived there two years four
years or six years ago
they don't want to do it the secretary
of state and your incompetent governor
although he thinks i've been a great
[Music]
president
they illegally flooded their states with
absentee ballots
and they deployed hundreds of illicit
ballot drop boxes in corrupt
democrat-run cities among many other
flagrant violations of what they put
these drop boxes there
and in a number of cases they'd be gone
for three days to take them up and they
where are they where are they they were
gone georgia's secretary of state agreed
to
a litigation settlement which is
something that nobody's ever seen one
like this
i want to just tell you that stacey
abrams took him to the cleaners
that's whose fault this really is
drastically and illegally change the
state's election procedures
they never got the mandated approval
from your state legislature
who by the way you have some great
people in your
legislature some great great people who
agree with what we're saying and even
more so
but think of it they never got the
approval you have to by law under the
constitution you can't just do these
deals and not get the approval
and your secretary of state or whoever
it was
made this horrible consent decree the
crowd doesn't quiet down we won't
be able to hear his lies so much safety
it's a disgraceful thing
and it was only approved by your local
politicians
him and local judges you can't do that
you have to have your state
legislatures do it that's true with all
states tens of thousands of votes are
missing
we go all over the world telling people
how to run their elections and we don't
even know
how to run hours now there's a few
layers to the irony of that actually
that that's actually
deeper than that that's very interesting
we could do an hour on that
the democrat party why the hell didn't
you do this for me
why didn't you do it for me
why the hell didn't you notice how quiet
she's been i shouldn't have said that
now tonight joe
what is this back you notice how quiet
she's furious because she said
photographers on a list
by 10 000 votes we did much better as i
said this time
much much better but i won michigan from
her by 10
000 votes i won wisconsin by a small you
know i mean
they could have done that one and not
get caught we caught them
we caught them and i say to people like
mike lee that are here and lindsay
i say if they got
approved and verified they use the word
verified
votes that are fraudulent and then we
find out after because you can't do it
that quickly it doesn't go that quickly
it's a lot of work
you guys following this people and then
we find out
that they were frauds like in one state
where you had let's say you lost by 25
000 votes
they verify it and that's supposed to be
the end but shortly thereafter we find
out that we actually won the state by
250 000 votes
does that mean that that state plus
others
adds up to being your president what is
he talking about i don't think it should
i have no idea what he's talking about
kelly feels it should
i don't think that marjorie feels it
should marjorie who cares what she's
wisconsin
over 90 000 ballots
can't do that not allowed to through
so-called human
drop boxes they reportedly fertilize
them
watered them and then harvested them in
addition
over 170 000 absentee votes
were counted that are blatantly illegal
under wisconsin law
and should never have been included in
the tally by the way i lost them
it was razor thin there's 170 000 votes
the margin in wisconsin is only 20 000
votes so
this issue alone would have won that
state for us
many times over we were leading
at 10 o'clock in the evening by a lot in
pennsylvania
there were two hundred and five thousand
more balances hey remember this is a
rally in support of david perdue who's
not even here because he's quarantined
and kelly lefler
and trump's going through the list of
votes unexplained you have great
senators and representatives there and
nobody can explain it
but think of that and in other places
too you had more
ballots than you had voters you had more
votes
that's that's untrue in addition
democrats state supreme court judges and
democrat
secretary of state effectively abolished
the signature verification process
right here they counted ballots cast
after deadlines and they allowed ballots
to be legally fixed
why is he talking about controlled areas
and i i say this because you can't let
this happen tomorrow and i hope all the
politicians are listening
there's an unexplained 400 000 vote
discrepancy
between the number of mail-in ballots in
pennsylvania sent out
reported on november 2nd 2020
not this again reported on november 4th
they can't explain it
400 000 previously unreported mail-in
ballots
yeah this is a good super chat he's
channeling your most boring statistics
professor
i had a guy my first year at umass for
some
requirement in the communications
department it was like introduction to
interpersonal communication and he used
an overhead projector when everybody had
laptops and whiteboards digital
whiteboard for some reason he used an
overhead projector with the squeaky
markers
and the average score on the midterm was
29
out of a hundred and guy was fired uh
i've never seen someone fired so
as soon as the semester was over the guy
was fired listening to him was like
listening to this stuff were you just
like what what
is this a math class a science class are
we are we
dissecting cadavers what are we doing
here it's illegally cast
by out-of-state voters those are numbers
and those are numbers we got from them
so they can't say oh the numbers aren't
so good
in clark county nevada over 130
000 ballots this is far just so you know
all these numbers these are far more
than
we need were processed on machines
where the signature matching threshold
was intentionally lowered to a level
that you could sign your name santa
claus
and it wouldn't pick it up didn't pick
up anything
more than 42 thousand people in nevada
double voted that's not
in arizona more than 36 000 votes were
cast by non-citizens
no and there were 11 000 more ballots
than there were voters not a single
non-citizen voted
they can't even register how they're
going to vote at the super bowl we have
15 cameras and they say camera number
four
you're on camera number three you're
wrong in michigan according to one
analyst
over 35 000 ballots listed no address
over 13 ballots were cast by
non-residents
and an estimated 17 000 ballots were
cast by dead people
that's all untrue some dead people by
the way also requested
an application it's true those are the
ones that really bother me
right not only vote but they request an
application that's a double
it trump's mad about that because it's
just you know the carbon footprint of
mailing things
matter of dominion voting machines
and i want you to watch this very
carefully tomorrow everybody you have to
watch it carefully i want to read you
from a letter from interstate senator
william
legon you know who he is right highly
respected guys what's the real
pronunciation of the last
year mr president is chairman of the
georgia senate judiciary committee on
elections
i request that you immediately send an
outside team of cyber experts to
investigate
potential hacking and other
irregularities associated with
dominion voting systems scanners
ballot marking devices ballots polling
pads
used in the 2020 general election in
georgia
you don't hear this from your secretary
this is like a poorly written
book report from a second grader you
have a great legislature i have to tell
you but the governor won't let him hold
the session to decertify
on december 30th 2020 the committee held
a hearing
investigating potential fraud and other
irregularities during georgia's 2020
general election
the committee first unanimously approved
a report
you know trump often says irregularities
do you think that he's
he thinks irregularities that that the
root is
rigged something being rigged as opposed
to irregular as in not regular is it
actually possible he thinks it's
rigged irregularities is that a
possibility
the november 3rd 2020 general election
was chaotic and reported results must be
viewed as
untrustworthy they are untrustworthy
despite the line of crap that you hear
from these people that represent you
i don't know where they come from the
committee then heard
and this is the crowd has lost highly
respected political representatives
the committee then heard additional
testimony concerning voting
irregularities during the 2020. can't
anybody like can't his kids sit after
these things and they've been going on
for years ago dad that was really bad
this is it's not good
it's not good people it's not this is
you're just ranting it's really not good
you should do a short speech and just
stay on the prompter can nobody reach
him and say this is stupid
voting machines in georgia to be
immediately conducted
the governor will not let us do it we've
been asking him now
since november 4th the day after the
election
he won't let us do it why won't he let
us do it
there's only one reason i can think
first the dominion voting machines
employed in fulton county
that's the home of stacy had an
astounding
93.67 error rate 93.67 error rate
in the scanning of ballots requiring a
review panel to adjudicate or determine
the voter's intent so they're going to a
voter intent
what did the voter mean by this vote
somebody votes for trump
you know i think that voter meant
something other he doesn't want trump
let's just switch it around
think of that they're trying to
determine the voter's intent
in over 106 000 ballots out of a total
of
113 000 ballots
this is from your representative highly
respected
the national average for such an error
rate is far less than one
do we think this will go on another 30
minutes
60 minutes or 90 minutes comical error
rate must be identified
to determine if these machines were set
up or designated to allow for a third
party
to disregard the actual ballot cast by
the registered voter this is what i have
there was no way look at this crowd we
have here biden came here he had
gopala
gallup gallup you know the gallup poll
they did i don't i don't say this
braggingly
the most admired man in the world or the
country
i don't say it i say it for a different
reason
so i came in first obama came in second
and biden came in way low
then i say and they say and people have
said
how is it possible that a guy who got 80
million votes
can't get any votes for the most admired
man you know why
because he didn't come in first oh my
god
second again from this
very respected political leader second
there is clear evidence that tens of
thousands of votes were switched
from president trump i feel like we're
on repeat
this is this is bizarre throughout
georgia
for example in bib county anybody live
in bib county
bibb that's a different state president
trump was reported to have
29 391 votes
at 9 11 p.m
while simultaneously former vice
president joe biden was reported to have
17 thousand two eighteen
really inspiring speech update these
vote
numbers switched with president trump
now having seventeen thousand
and biden now having twenty nine
thousand three hundred ninety one
you guys writing down these numbers that
was a switch of over 12
000 votes it was like a miracle
third during this hearing a presenter
demonstrated that a dominion i wonder if
this is some subtle way to you know how
trump says he doesn't want to do these
speeches for other people he doesn't
want to do rallies
you think that they sit and they go hey
listen let's do a two-hour
speech where you just read county by
county election
results just to piss off the people
you're supposed to be helping
and lull the crowd to sleep so they'll
be too tired to even vote tomorrow like
could he be doing this to screw them
over thinking what's the most boring
speech i could possibly give
shape or form did you see that during
the hearing
this guy's sitting there well can you
connect into the machines yes
how do you do that within about 25
seconds
he controlled the internet former vice
president biden
led georgia by only 11
779 votes every one of the things i told
you about almost is more votes than what
we're talking about
the crime that was committed in this
state is immeasurable
an immediate forensic audit of an
appropriate sampling of dominions voting
machines
i insist we need forensic ontologists to
come in and check the dental
the the teeth of every voter and make
sure they match what their dentists have
on file
and during tomorrow's race you've got to
be very careful
if they have dentists and let me also
quickly read a letter from mark fincham
chairman of the arrow quickly house a
very respected man
federal relations committee dear mr
president
subsequent to the election members of
the legislature were inundated with
complaints
from constituents relating to the
intensity of the general election
and the integrity more important than
anything else
and the accuracy of canvas results
in many instances constituents reported
that their
earlier in-person ballots may not have
been correctly processed or tabulated in
maya they should play him off like just
start ymca
and slowly raise the volume just in
recent weeks
during which significant evidence of
fraudulent and illegal voting in arizona
has been demonstrated
through expert and eyewitness testimony
for example in pima county
and miacopa county it appears that 143
000 illegal votes
were actually injected into the ballot
system injection
no but think of this also and you know
the press won't report this they're
probably turning off oh we don't like
this
they don't like this they don't want to
talk about numbers they talked about my
phone call they don't like my phone call
everyone loved my phone call they don't
like talking about numbers
because nobody knew the numbers were so
egregious
also an expert mathematician concluded
that the only explanation for the actual
voting results in arizona
is that 100 percent think of this
130 percent of democrats voted for
candidate biden
and a negative 30 voted for president
trump
now think of that in order to get to the
numbers
130 how is this real life
that's a little tough to get okay
had a vote for him and minus 30 had a
vote for me
and that gets you to 100 and nobody has
a 100
voting for all of these people who think
it's too late
does that mean that we're forced to
approve a fraudulent election or an
election
with massive you're not forced to do
anything you won't be president in 16
days
i don't think so i want to thank those
two great
political leaders but we have many other
letters just like that
same thing hundreds of thousands of
votes
the only way to combat the democrat
fraud is to flood your polling places
with a historic tidal wave of republican
voters tomorrow
because at a certain point the machines
are going to explode
there you go unfortunately they didn't
quite get there but
that's an idea and i just want mike lee
to listen to this when i'm talking
explosive machines we need his vote this
election is your chance to stand
up to the corrupt democrat machine and
show them that the american people
are still in charge
with your help over the last four years
we built the greatest political movement
in the history of our country
there's never been anything like this
kelly when did i
say we'll do this like two days there's
never been an authoritarian attempt by a
sitting president
to force state officials to just give
him
the election that's what there's never
been before presidents have lost many
many times before
i say it all the time and the
politicians the lame stream media as i
call them affectionately
if that weren't true they'd say that's
wrong there's never been a movement like
this
i mean you have people that won one
state
and they become world famous for the
rest of their lives you have people that
came in second in new hampshire and
their world
we won everything and we want it now a
second time
sounds like jealousy in some weird ways
but we want it now a second time
and i don't want to win it a third time
i really want to win it the second time
it's
harder wow somebody came up to me today
kelly and they said
sir you're way up in four years
nobody can come close to me i said i'm
not interested in four years i'm
interested in like eight weeks ago
right well it didn't happen didn't
happen it's a long time
it's actually two and two you know we'll
take back the house for kevin
right and marjorie jody we'll bring back
the house
right we'll bring back that sir do you
understand counting
no if we didn't win i'd be all set of
course if i didn't win you probably
wouldn't want me you know no fair
you didn't win big difference between
losing and
winning and happening the crowd is
pretty damn quiet no but they talk about
four years sir you haven't made nobody
can come close
they're moving the limo unclear what
that signals
and i think we're gonna do it i really
believe because there's no way
we could have won every single state and
for fox
not one state this is one of many we win
every state
and they're going to have this guy be
president this is seditious right what
he's doing can anybody
gut check me already we've achieved more
than anyone
thought possible and we are just getting
started
and and honestly it's you it's amazing
what happened i don't even know why the
hell i say let's have a rally we have a
rally in thousands and thousands of
people
honestly there's never been i'll go out
on the extreme
there's never been anything like this in
the history of our country
and the election now he's going to say
something crazy
and we have a big one tomorrow but
there's never been anything like this in
the history of our country
our economy is coming back it's roaring
back our stock market is an all-time
high who would have thought that
we're rounding the term because of the
turn because of what we did
with the vaccines and nobody else would
have done it it would have taken so long
the economy boomed
at 33.4 percent last week the crowds
like we don't even wear masks because we
don't believe this is serious
but trump's great because of the vaccine
which we probably aren't gonna get i
guess
during a pandemic we've already slashed
the unemployment rate in half
and for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding foreign
nations
fighting far in wars and defending
foreign borders you know we're bringing
many of our great troops home i mean i
hate to say but
got to do it we've been in afghanistan
for 19 years i think that's enough
i think that's enough we've got a lot of
uh very few left
and uh very proud nothing worse than
going to dover
and meeting the parents of our great
warriors that have
fallen i thought trump wasn't doing that
but he was sending pens
and on countries that many of you have
never even heard about
so we bring our soldiers home we've been
incredible warriors
we can beat anybody nobody has our
equipment nobody has our military nobody
has our people
but we aren't over there to be policemen
good news guys the pilots just got back
into the chopper that's a good sign
and that's what we want them for that's
what we have to have them for
but we brought a lot of them home we are
finally protecting our nation rebuilding
our cities
and we're bringing our jobs our
factories and our troops
back to the usa where they belong
but everything that we've achieved
together is on the line tomorrow
our fight to take back our country from
the big donors the big media
and the horrendous big tech giants that
our politicians not these two
politicians
are afraid to attack section 230 we have
to get rid of sex
so what was the case he made for voting
for lefleur
and purdue i'm not sure i caught it very
long taking away all your rights if you
want to send a message to the powerful
forces that
are trying to control your country
you must get out and vote tomorrow for
david perdue and kelly lefler
with your help we're going to continue
our mission
to save america and we're going to
continue
our mission of america first
it's very simple all right each of us
here tonight is united by the same core
vision
and the same timeless american values we
love our country
together we believe that faith and
family not government and bureaucracy
are the center of american life
we will defend the right to life
religious liberty
this is it guys this is the last rally
the rasp last bizarre
up and maybe the last time he'll dance
like a [ __ ]
and we will always support the heroes of
law enforcement
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will preserve peace through
strength you know when i first
got elected and before i got elected in
2015 and
2016 before they were in debates and
everyone said
oh he's going to cause wars he's going
to cause wars
i think wars in many many decades that
didn't
get into a war
remember north korea was going to be a
tremendous nuclear fight and
all this what happened with that i got
along very well with
kim jong-un completely bamboozled him
this is what happened i've heard but
but i got along very well with him and
you know people say whatever happened
with north korea we got along well
but you know they all said that with my
personality i'll be in a big war very
soon within the first two weeks right
what happened what happened and they
don't want to mess with us either
that i can tell you david and kelly will
protect social security and medicare
and they will always protect patients
with pre-existing conditions
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our schools oh
give me a break
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect our
great american flag
and we will live by the words of our
nation
half a million dead in a pandemic per a
cdc estimate and he's talking about
flags
from atlanta to augusta to savannah to
columbus
from athens and i want to say hello to
herschel walker athens
athens georgia one of our first radio
affiliates is in athens georgia
wpp i think he made a lot of
quarterbacks look very good we love
herschel
to right here in dalton georgia we
inherit the legacy of generations of
american patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears to
defend our country and
to defend our freedom we stand on the
shoulders of american heroes who crossed
the oceans
settled the continent tamed the
wilderness laid down
the railroads raised up the great
skyscrapers and won
two world wars defeated fascism and
communism and made america into the
single
greatest nation in the history of the
world
and the best is yet to come
this is so flaccid given the
circumstances
and proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
our fight to drain the washington swamp
and reclaim
america's destiny and dignity has
only just begun we will not bend we will
not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up we will never back
down
we will never ever surrender right
other than he will surrender the white
house in 16 days because we are
americans and we are from georgia
and our hearts bleed red white and blue
[Music]
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of georgia
we have made america powerful again our
military
oh no we have made america
wealthy again our stock market this may
be the last time we ever hear this
america stronger
bit of a glitch there we have made
america proud again we're proud of our
country he's glitching out
we have made america safe again
and we will make america
great again go get him david go get him
kelly
go get him tomorrow and he's done
let's see if they do the music
[Applause]
and we'll play our own music which we
have
they didn't bother to interview a single
witness just like you
they don't want to know the truth well
you probably know the truth
okay so so there's rudy passing gas
but the content of this was also
disgusting this went on for hours
there it is
[Laughter]
perfect oh it's perfect
oh my god it's perfect there's rudy
passing gas
[Music]
just like you they don't want to know
the truth
well you probably know the truth
[Music]
why don't you look at the registered
voters on there
how many registered voters are on there
there it is oh it's too perfectly timed
oh the wacky noise when he was that's
just unbelievable
what about what about how what about the
turnout right
120 percent
witness all right so there it is um okay
donald trump's last rally as president i
think unless something were to get
scheduled
unbelievably perfect timing there with
the rudy giuliani fart song so
as promised listen guys let's go to the
phones i said if we got 100 members and
twitch subs i would open phones we got
440.
do you understand 440 the goal was 100
okay if you are leaving come back
tomorrow night for georgia election
results live
um make sure to subscribe on youtube and
follow on
twitch tomorrow night we'll be back with
election results
if you're staying and you want to talk
to me right now
go to our discord davidpakman.com
discord get into the waiting
lobby change your nickname
to location and then your name
location and then your name and then i'm
gonna talk to you
okay let's just listen to some people
because there's so many people here
uh waiting to talk let's get right to it
uh oh hold on a second i'm not even
connected yet i have to be i have to be
properly connected if we're gonna
actually do this
uh i'm not even in the waiting lobby
here we go all right let's go to marie
from ohio marie from ohio how are you
uh thanks i am great
this is marie uh yes yes actually yes
what's on your mind marie and so i'm
echoing and we can hear discord in the
background
uh try to hear that
uh i'll make this quick all right please
first and foremost uh i'd like to uh
apologize saying your mouth is wide
it was a joke that
didn't land right clearly apology
accepted
a very fine mouth good sir thank you
right so trump is gonna be out of office
and uh tell me if you already heard this
question before but
he is going to be the leader of the
republican party basically until he dies
at this point
i don't know that i think that remains
to be seen i think he may just disappear
i i don't i think we won't know that
until probably february or march
oh if he is or at least what is the
republican party after this point
it'll depend on whether trump disappears
or tries to remain at its forefront
i think we just won't i have a couple
clips about this um we just won't know
until february or march
do you think it's gonna like sort of
shift the overton window back to the
right
sort of like a reagan type thing i think
if trump fades away
the republican party instantly goes back
to oh we care about the dead and you
know the going back to the same old
thing they've been doing that's my
prediction if trump does just bail
uh interesting interesting
all right marie thank you very much
great to hear from you i appreciate it
we're taking calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord in the waiting
lobby is the place to be let's go
next to um johnny
from michigan you were on the air
johnny from michigan you're on the air
microphone working hello hello how are
you johnny
i am doing fantastic how about you i'm
doing well
is that your dog in the background is it
oh yeah no sorry about that what kind of
dog is that but
it's i actually am not entirely sure
she's like this weird little fuzz ball
there's like a girl holding retriever
chow mix yeah
um anyways what i was sort of wondering
is
um what do at this point
about supporters and you know
my whole thing is that and we were doing
this in your discord earlier is that
there's a group of people who are so
like far gone in terms of like their
grip of reality
yes facts and just anything these people
that have blindly followed this man for
four years
i know and don't accept anything
that doesn't fit them i don't know what
we do i mean listen if you just look at
trump's 90-minute speech tonight or
however
80 minutes 90 minutes if you only
believe
one percent of what trump said you're
still believing some lies
i mean he told hundreds and hundreds of
lies so if you say
i'm skeptical i'm gonna disbelieve 99
of what trump told me tonight you're
still believing lies and and i don't
know how we fix that i don't know
and some of those people as is being
pointed out in the chat are
like that marjorie taylor green woman
she's one of the nuts that believes
trump's lies
she won and is now going to be in the
house of representatives we're we're
really in rough shape
it's bad it's a whole generation then
right yeah it's a whole
it's a generational issue it took us
since reagan 30 40 years to get
to where things are this bad it's going
to take a long time to improve them and
it's a sad reality
and real quick um what a what about the
more like working class like trump
voters like the people that aren't so
bound by ideology like is there room to
kind of i guess see the light of day
i think the best some of the best
writing i've read about that issue is by
jonathan height who talks about like why
do these middle class right wingers or
middle
middle lower middle class right wingers
working class whatever the right term is
at this point
why do they support republican policy um
check out jonathan heights work on that
and sort of like group
level thinking rather than individual he
he can talk he can explain that far
better than i can
alright thank you my pleasure great to
hear from you
uh we are taking calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
slash discord we are going to try to get
diversity
of everything let's go next to jessica
in chicago jessica you're on the air
jessica please unmute so that we can
hear you you are on the air we just need
you to unmute yourself i can see that
you are muted right now
and jessica from chicago third and final
opportunity to unmute yourself and talk
to me you are on the air
all right that's too bad no jessica
let's go
next to connor from england connor from
england you're on the air um hello
hello so what's your opinion on
non um politicians who
are not having any background in
politics
say for instance like trump has no um
background in
politics politics are military
yeah white knowledge whatsoever i have
no problem so
military i have no concern with
whatsoever there is a very clear
uh you know decision tree and and way
for
civilian presidents without military
experience to be advised by the top
military people
i have no concerns there whatsoever i
love the idea
of non-career politicians as presidents
but they shouldn't be low-rent scam
artists like trump
i would love the idea of you know
a uh a social studies professor
a human geography professor would be a
dramatically better president than trump
someone from science uh a doc
a medical doctor with an mba
you i mean it's like almost any profi i
love this idea
and you know we need a peanut farmer
sure we need more than just
lawyers and politicians as as presidents
or scam businessmen
uh yeah absolutely all right thank you
very much
and by the way so where you're where in
england are you at leads
leads i've never had the pleasure what
what's different culturally in leeds
compared to london
um it's mostly a metropolitan area with
uh more offices than um tourism spots
okay very good have you ever been to
dishoom in london
oh no i don't travel much out of the
town all right well i recommend it i
look forward to getting to lead sometime
thank you i appreciate it
there is connor from england very very
exciting
we are hearing from people um from all
over the world
let's go next to efrain from argentina
my birth nation
you're on the air
[Music]
hey can you hear me yes i can come with
us
i'm great i'm estoy muy bien thank you
for having me
mike it's my pleasure so i just want to
say it's really impressive
i follow trump's speeches i've followed
his speeches for since he started his
political career
yeah and it's unbelievable the amount of
lies he can
pack up in a minute of speech it's crazy
well uh we have a lot of that in in our
countries in latin america and argentina
we had a lot of that
but what's what i wonder is how he has
managed to
be so like our politicians in latin
america and other
populist politicians in the world i mean
do you guys have any track
of how he learned all of that lying
into people's faces so easily and so
quickly this is the second time i got
this question
like the the earlier version of the
question was where did trump learn these
authoritarian fascistic ideas
i think that they if you are a
delusional
narcissist who has never been told no in
your life
and you're hungry for power and believe
the world revolves around you
i think you naturally gravitate to these
things
that these right-wing populists and
authoritarians and wannabe dictators and
i don't think they talk to each other
and say this is how you do it
i think they end up there naturally
because of their disposition
yeah and it's really incredible i mean
the parallels i am originally from
venezuela
but the problems with uh trump with hugo
chavez
the late hugo chavez and some of the
living leaders we have in argentina
christina kirschner
even the current president is uncanny
yes
the ease with which he can say all those
things and see
people not that many because at the end
most people were just silent
yeah but so many people are cheering for
that and replicating that in media
it's crazy makes me wonder i have family
in the u.s i follow your politics a lot
because i really like it it's
entertaining
even though it's really dramatic and
incredible to watch
but i can't believe how it has gotten
and my
my final question to you is how do you
feel america
going out of this i mean there's a half
of the country or so
that has bought this lice and are
repeating them like
you know parrots i don't have the answer
but what i know is it will be a long
process as i said before it took 40 30
40 years since
the reaganization of politics started
and got us
into this delusion for half the country
it will likely take
more than a decade to get out of it in
the best case i think we have to come to
grips with that and realize this is a
long-term project
yeah i hope you guys can get out of it
and get to united country again
soon yeah so listen are you in buenos
aires or somewhere else
yes sir buenos aires what what
neighborhood
uh palermo really oh that's where i
always stay when i visit
oh i'm glad you you come here yeah i
usually stay up when you come back
i usually rent a place uh like a few
blocks off of
santa fe near kind of like near
scalarini ortiz a little closer to
downtown actually than that
that's very close to my previous house
like really really close
italia one other question i've i've seen
that there is a new havana alfajor which
is
very dark chocolate i think they call it
the black one are you familiar with this
of course and is it is it good i've
never had this new
black chocolate well if you like dark
chocolate
you're gonna love it beautiful beautiful
i may place an order on pampa direct
tonight
please do okay all right thank you
afraid great great to talk to a uh
fellow argentinian there wow a perfect
phone call
let's go next to kalyn in austin texas
kalin in austin texas
hello hi how are you i'm good this is
amazing
how are you david i'm doing well
um i'm uh i'm a newcomer fan
my mom she's a huge fan she's um watches
you religiously
she's so beautiful you know that uh she
wouldn't watch any of this stuff if it
wasn't for you
i love it i love it so my question is
is do you think there will be any
justice or peace for any of us that are
like
completely mad about every wrong thing
that he's ever done i mean
i believe he's responsible for a lot of
people's deaths yeah um i
i think sadly the answer is no i think
we're going to we have to manage
expectations and i think
we are going to have to be satisfied
most likely with
he's only getting one term not to and
he will be sort of annoyed by
investigations for many years none of
which will lead to him being in prison
so so i think we have to manage that but
he will just sort of
for the rest of his life kind of have
the feeling that
man maybe that really wasn't worth it
after all and i think that that's what
we're going to have to be satisfied with
quite frankly
but what about the standard for
everybody else isn't it i know
you know i know i mean listen get away
with who else
we learned during this presidency that
the checks and balances we thought were
really durable
never accounted for someone becoming
president who would disregard
the norms the way trump has that's a
learning experience
it's a damaging experience as well but
that has been a learning experience i
think you're absolutely right well
thank you for taking my question my
pleasure great to hear from you
kailyn in beautiful austin texas
with no state income tax as many of you
know very appealing to a lot of people
okay let's go next to gisella from new
york
gisela from new york you are on the air
hello can you hear me yes i can where in
new york are you
i'm in queens queens love it i used to i
used to go to quit oh long
lic okay um i i don't even know if these
places still exist
because of the pandemic but there is
a tremendous argentinian restaurant in
the elmhurst
corona area of queens called write this
down now
uh gisela el gauchito this is the place
to go
once the pandemic is over
i absolutely love that place oh you've
been there you've been there
yes wow yes i i i'm argentinian
oh you are oh okay why am i i don't have
to explain it to you then wow
okay perfect so um i've been following
you
found you on youtube and and i had two
questions for you actually
please you allow me actually one comment
and a question
what while i was watching your live
stream
i got served an ad for
the right that immigrants shouldn't have
rights and
what all the other things that are very
nice
of the right wing to say so i think
that's
you know justice because at least you're
getting some revenue
so i i just watched it and let them
speak
just beautiful money to you if you see
right wing ads on my video
just watch the ads because you're
literally taking money from these right
wing nuts
and giving it to progressive independent
media gisela perfect strategy
yes and i want everyone else to do that
if you see
an ad on facebook on google everywhere
just click on it
to consume it because that takes money
away from them
absolutely that's one thing perfect
recommendation
yes and the question that i have is
i i am inside of the argentinian
community in new york and i was
appalled to see the amount of
argentinians
that came here as immigrants like me and
your family i don't know your story i'm
sorry yeah i was born in buenos aires i
was five when i moved to the us
oh so you know our story and there was a
lot of trump supporters
not all of them not all of them
hopefully not the majority i don't know
but really hard for me to understand how
fellow immigrants especially from
argentina yeah
and vote for someone like him
yeah no i mean listen most most
argentinians
most latin americans other than cubans
are very liberal and i'm part of a big
uh what's i'm part of a couple of
argentinian groups
and i've experienced that also like just
yesterday there was one where people
were
sending vaccine conspiracies about bill
gates like all the same ones that we see
in english they were being sent around
in spanish and i jumped in and i said
this is this is dangerous and widely
debunked uh the secretary italo was
the exact word that i used and um i i
mean it is concerning but
um statistically it's not that common
yeah i mean and
i hope things get better for all of us
thank you for the recommendation on
egochito absolutely for everyone to know
we have a tradition in argentina i don't
know if there's any other country that
does this
but they give you calendars here
you know in argentina so when you buy
from a small business they will give you
a calendar of the upcoming year
yes and it was the only argentinian
place in here that gave me a calendar so
i really appreciate
that beautiful i love it okay gisela
amazing wow what a day let's go to mike
from miami florida mike from miami
you're on the air
hello hello hey david
big fan of the show thank you um i just
wanted to guess you follow up from
the last question i'm cuban american
here in miami as well and
100 right about the hispanic groups and
how cubans are
yeah um so my question is for um
the runoff election tomorrow i've been
seeing a lot of uh
early election predictions that
democrats have been coming out more to
vote
are we gonna expect like a red mirage
tomorrow again or
i really don't know you know i plan to i
hope everybody will join me tomorrow
night for election results in georgia
i don't expect we will know the results
tomorrow night i mean look at how close
look at how long it took to get us to a
runoff
in the counting of the results from
november 4th
so i don't i don't know about a red
mirage but i don't think we will have
the results tomorrow night i think
that's as far as i can really say
confidently right now
all right cool thanks for the answer
what's what's going on down in miami
these days oh it's uh a little crazy
down here i mean our
mayor doesn't really you know pay
attention to the chronovirus
yep um we have thousands of cases new
cases every day
i saw video of uh collins in miami beach
on the 30th not the 31st but no
december 30th and it was just a mass of
people with no masks
yeah it's crazy actually today i went to
the dmv and thankfully uh to renew my
license
and there was a police to help keep
everyone six feet apart and use
their mass but yeah generally you go
anywhere near miami and it's like if
nothing's changed
yep since the pandemic started it's sad
miami miami is one of my favorite places
and i uh i'm re i was scheduled to go
down there
and basically a week after the big trump
speech saying he's banning flights from
china
and obviously the trip got cancelled and
and i've not i've not been but i look
forward to getting back down there
yeah that'd be awesome all right thanks
so much for the call i appreciate it
thank you all right take care lots of
lots of nice folks today that want to
chat that's always great
let's go uh let we'll do just a couple
more
because we do have a very very big big
day
let's do one more from miami this is
misha from miami you're on the air misha
hey can you hear me yes oh my god thank
you
so much for taking my call david
pleasure now misha i have to ask
when when one hears misha you think
russian but being from miami
there's lots of russian cubans in miami
i'm one yeah you are a russian cuban
interesting see
i think that some people would have
assumed you were actually
just russian but i think the russian
cuban aspect is in play anytime you hear
miami that's a lesson to everybody
that's right my last name is or maybe i
shouldn't say but yeah don't say your
last name don't say less
uh okay good all right well you're on so
uh
i'm young uh i'm relatively new to to
politics
i'm very interested in it uh something
that kind of terrifies me just looking
at this
uh rally here is just and is a bit of a
two-parter i guess
first of all has it always been this way
where people could just like
lie like about your own positions like
say i'm for social security i'm poor
uh you know what's it called the pre-con
uh
pre-existing conditions even though
clearly if republicans were in charge
they take it away
like is that is that always been this
way and if it's new how do we fight
against it
there has always been a ton of lying in
politics
but i have never seen it the way donald
trump does it which is just to tell
provable lies
one after another after another for an
hour and a half i've never seen it this
bad but yeah
lying in politics has existed for a long
time
okay and and this is kind of a big
question but
do you have any i mean if this is the
new normal that yeah trump has brought
in like this
uh this politics of just
pathological lying mm-hmm what do we do
well one part is let's see what happens
when trump leaves
but the truth is i i have a video clip
called
it's something like what do we do about
75 million trumpists and i talk about
how this will take a long
period of dealing with education and
dealing with culture
and it's not going to be an easy fix
there's no easy fix that's i think the
takeaway
yeah so true it's sad well thank you
david
pleasure all right there's misha from
miami
let's go next to michelle from los
angeles california
michelle oh and michelle's gone okay
that's too bad michelle uh seemed to
self-kick
that was kind of uh kind of unusual uh
okay there was somebody else i had my
eye on here
was from an interesting location but now
i
oh i'm told jessica from chicago wants
another shot
jessica from chicago weird i'm going
back to you
what's going on jessica from chicago
oh boy jessica
all right no jessica all right guys
that's going to do it for me we've got
very very long streams coming up both
tomorrow night and wednesday plus the
podcast
tv show and i've got to do my spanish
show so this is where
i am going to cut it uh if you are
watching me
over on uh twitch we are going to send
a very strong raid
over to who we're going to rate let's
raid the chess bras
over on twitch all right so if you're
watching there with that that's not
something i've done before we'll do that
and i will be back tomorrow night with
you guys
for these very very important election
results i'll see you then
should i play this this is one of the
most vile callers we have
take a listen to the i have not
pre-screened this so i let me just